Here we go. And boom, we're lot Graham.
Great to see you again. Nice to be away.
Um, and we were just talking about your,
your new book America before that.
There's two versions of it.
There's one version and then there's a
newer version that's a Barnes and noble
version that's specific to Barnes and
noble that has an extra whole chapter in
it. That's correct. Yeah. And so they
can get that at Barnes and noble.
I'm just trying to keep bookstores
alive men through either way.
I think it's really important.
And that's,
and that's what are the reasons
that I did this because, because I,
I had finished the book and then
Barnes and noble came to me through my
publishes and ad said they would like
to do a special edition of the book,
but in order to do that, I needed to
write them some extra material. Uh,
Adam and I had a lot of material that
I hadn't put in the book and I thought,
well, this is an opportunity to
put that out there. Beautiful.
So if people want that, it's a little
bit different than there's a small goal.
Okay. So festival, my website,
Graham hancock.com has a page about
America before and the link to the Barnes
and noble edition is there as well
as the link to the standard edition,
which is on Amazon and iTunes and all
kinds of all kinds of other places.
So Graham hancock.com and
the America before page.
The link to the bonds of double edition is
right there. All right, there it is. So,
um, how has this, Oh,
before we even get into what does
it go to talks and events. Okay,
we're on the Graham Hancock website.
Go to books.
So I and fucks go to America before Bam,
Bam.
Go to United States.
You can see Amazon bods and there's
Barnes and nobles, special edition.
Nationalization. Click on that. There
you go. And then the Ebook as well,
the ebook audio book, which I
read myself, x is available there.
And then if you scroll down, um,
oops, that shouldn't be there.
Damn popups son.
I am so happy you read it yourself.
I get angry when someone
else reads someone who I'm
like, come on, he can talk.
Yeah, I enjoy reading. What
books myself and what I've,
what I've learned from feedback I get
from audiences at presentations is people
like me doing that. Oh
yeah, for sure. Yeah. Yeah,
a hundred percent it's just weird when
someone else is talking in your voice
like, hey man, I know you're not cramped.
You know that I write fiction as well
as the [inaudible] and the one thing I
can't read is my fiction really well.
Yeah, because fictions requires accents.
You really need an access
to read a fiction book who
can get into the different
characters. But for a nonfiction
book like America before,
it's very straightforward for me
just to read it myself, I agree.
I'm a tremendous Stephen King Fan,
but when I read Stephen King's books
where he reads them or listen to him when
he reads them of their terrible,
he's awful at it.
I don't think at Novelis should,
should read there. Bare on levels.
I think that's it. That's a
job for an actor. Oddly enough,
I've just been reading Stephen King's
dark tower series that just very near the
end of the seventh volume of that. Yeah.
I'm just a giant fan of his. But man,
when he reads it, he reads it like he's
just reading it. Yeah. It's like, Ooh,
this is rough. It's hard to get
behind anyway. Um, America before.
So there's, give us the website,
there's, there's details about the book,
there's a page where there
are links to the book.
And also the other thing I would like to
take this opportunity to mention is I'm
in America and Canada for the next
seven weeks and I'm going to be doing
something like 25 presentations in
something like 20 American cities and then
three Canadian cities in,
in Vancouver, Montreal,
Toronto and that's all on the talks
and events page of my website.
So if everybody wants to come along
and meet this old man in person,
uh,
I will be Elvis doing those events.
And Are you doing these at
theaters and you allow Q and A's?
Absolutely. I allow, I allow Q
and A's. I encourage that. I,
I feel as an author that frankly speaking,
I'm nothing without my audience.
I owe my audience,
my readers big time.
And what I try to do at events
is to give back as much as I can.
So if people want to take pictures
with me, I am absolutely up for that.
I don't understand why anybody
would want to do that, but it's fun.
It's kind of fun.
I wouldn't be more to come to the desk
where I'm signing and asked me personal
questions. I'm ready to do that.
Sometimes on the British book tour,
which I just finished,
I was behind in the,
in the event space for
four hours after the event,
finished siding and taking and taking
pictures. But it's a joy. It's an,
it's a really opportunity
for me to interact with the,
with with the people who actually make
my work matters. So that's fantastic.
Beautiful. So what inspired this? I
know there's, there's always been,
well, you, first of all, we should
just say for people who don't know,
you have been at the front of the line
for decades talking about these lost
civilizations and w w w,
w from reading your work.
I mean, I think our first
read your work in the 90s,
you exposed me to a lot of these,
what were at the time controversial
ideas that have now been substantiated by
actual evidence, particularly go back
like tapping and I mean the, the, the,
all the water erosion stuff on the
Sphinx and I've since had doctor Robert
Schoch on the podcast to talk about
that as well. But all this stuff, um,
was at one point very controversial
and now far less. Yes.
I mean whatever traditional academics and
traditional historians that are trying
to, I guess is archeologists
that we're trying to resist,
they've let go a lot of that. They've had
to, with things like go right, actually
tapped.
They've had to because they have it dead,
it says as overwhelmed them and go back
to the, he is an excellent example.
Prior to the discovery and
excavation of Quebec Tepi, uh,
which is a site in Anatolia in Turkey,
it was the view,
very firm view of archeologists that
there had been no megalithic architecture
anywhere on earth. And when I say
Megalithic, I mean literally big stones,
stone circles, huge constructions,
nothing like that before at the very,
very earliest, 6,000 years ago. And they
would point to sites in, for example,
Malta, a site called [inaudible],
which is about 5,800 years old.
That's the oldest megalithic
architecture in the world.
And they could understand how that was
because these were agricultural societies,
they generated surpluses.
You could free up people who could
become specialists in architecture,
in astronomy and geometry,
and they could apply their skills
to the construction of these sites.
But what they never considered possible
was that a society that was hunter
gatherers would have created a gigantic
megalithic site and then suddenly go
back. Lee Tapi is discovered,
it dates to 11,600 years ago.
It's more than 5,000 years older
than the supposedly oldest megalithic
architecture in the world.
And it is in the center where there had
been no previous evidence of agriculture.
But the moment go back in Tempe appears
agriculture appears as well. Um,
and this is just something that's
really hard for archaeology to explain.
They've suddenly got
5,000 years of missing,
of missing history that they've
just never taken into account.
And what I see them doing is largely
avoiding the problem rather than getting,
getting to grips with it directly.
And in fact, there have been,
there have been a great number of changes
in the last 20 years, which, which,
uh, have worked generally in favor of the
arguments that I've, that I've proposed.
Well,
I'm so happy for you because I know that
for a long time you were out there on
your own a lot of these theories
very, very much so. And, and uh,
also subjected to the most,
the most blistering and deeply
unpleasant criticism from,
uh, from the archeological fraternity
and from their friends in the, in,
in the media. Like how
dare this journalist, uh,
propose that history might be different
or that we might have a forgotten
chapter in the human story.
It was regarded almost as offensive that
I would put this material out there and
archeologist felt it was
their responsibility to show
the public that I was full
of shit. And that was, and that
was the whole way my work was,
was greeted and to a certain extent
still is greeted by a Kale juice.
But things have changed. Central to my
work was the notion of a global cataclysm,
roughly twelve thousand five hundred
twelve thousand eight hundred years ago.
There was,
it made sense to me in 1995 when
I wrote fingerprints of the gods,
but there was no compelling
evidence for a global cataclysm.
Then I just add all the evidence seems
to point to that time and a massive
global event. And then from
2007 onwards, you know,
more than a decade after I
wrote fingerprints of the Gods,
we get a group of more than
60 major scientists who are
seriously proposing that
the earth was hit by multiple fragments
of a giant comment 12,800 years ago.
And that this caused a huge rise in sea
level and extinctions of mega foreigners.
They are not saying that it also wiped
out a lost advanced civilization of
prehistory. I'm saying
that, but, but what,
what has changed is that we now have
compelling hard scientific evidence.
I'm not saying every scientist accepts it.
It's the nature of science
to dispute findings.
But we have a group of 60 major figures
who have seriously proposed this in all
the leading mainstream journals. And it's
changed the balance of power in this,
in this argument.
Because one thing that they used to say
is Hancock can't be right because there
was no global cataclysm, you
know, 12 or thousand years ago.
Well now we know there was and there
are various explanations for it.
So that's moved things along.
And the other thing that's changed a
lot is the attitude of the man in the
street to authority that has changed.
Back in the nineties authority
figures were the gatekeepers.
They controlled everything.
If the authority figure in a
discipline like archaeology said,
Hancock is completely wrong.
He's made all this stuff up that would
generally be believed not by everybody,
but by the majority of
people today to have a,
a mainstream authority figures say that
to me is actually an advantage because
people are so distrustful of authority
and rightly so because we've been lied to
by authority figures in
all fields for so long.
The bullshit has been so enormous
that people are finally waking up.
But we can't trust what
authority figures say.
And I think we can thank
the Internet for that.
We can thank the Internet for that.
You,
I'm sure you've seen the more recent
evidence of a crater that they just
discovered like fairly recently.
Greenland. Yes. Enormous
and north and enormous.
It's an enormous crater. Uh,
it's, um, 18 miles wide. Uh,
it had not been discovered
before because it's under ice.
It's under a lot of ice.
At the end of the ice age,
Greenland was one area which never
lost its ice cover completely,
whereas North America, everywhere north
of Minnesota was covered in ice, a mild,
sometimes two miles deep.
Europe, the same northern Europe.
But greed land kept its eyes,
whereas the other parts of the
world lost their eyes at the,
at the end of the ice age.
And what's interesting about Greenland
is there's already evidence of a comet
impact in Greenland,
which goes back to papers published in
the proceedings of the National Academy
of Sciences in 2013 that they found what
a called impact proxies in Greenland.
In other words, Nano
diamonds, carbons fails,
and no evidence of a lot of
platinum and an iron, uh,
was found in a layer in the ice
data to 12,000, 800 years ago.
But the next development
that you're absolutely right,
and this was just a few months ago,
was the discovery of this humongous crater
in Greenland and evidence that it was
caused by an iron impact her of some kind.
Now dating of it.
I would be irresponsible to say that
that crater definitely dates to 12,800
years ago because the work has
not been done to prove that yet.
But what I can say and
what the specialists who
have explored an excavator,
the crater are saying is that it's recent,
uh,
they can say for sure that it
happened during the last ice age.
Under it under the crater is nothing but
massively disturbed and destroyed and
completely wrecked ice from the ice age,
from the place to sit above it is smooth,
perfect ice from our epoch,
which is called the Holocene,
which began about 11,600 years ago.
So all the evidence suggests that this
created dates to that period between
twelve thousand eight hundred and
eleven thousand six hundred years ago,
but to absolutely confirm that
more work needs to be done,
but it's part of a growing pattern.
The younger dryas impact to they is,
they call themselves,
they call this the younger
dryas impact hypothesis.
And it's because there was a period in,
in the earth's geological history that
geologists called the younger dryas,
which lasted for 1,200 years,
from 12,800 to 11,600 years ago.
It's a very mysterious period.
We see all the megafauna dying
off suddenly and rapidly.
We see rises in sea level. We see a huge
collapse in global temperature. It's a,
it's a cataclysmic, a
epoch. And, and what, what,
what is becoming clearer and clearer,
uh,
is that the evidence that a
comet behind it was behind it is,
it is extremely strong.
And as more and more evidence comes in,
we realized how widespread it was.
So they found evidence of the impact
as far south as Antarctica. Now,
previously they were focused
very much on North American.
Now as far south as Antarctica, as far
east as Syria, this was truly a global,
a global event and it changed the world.
And I think,
and it's my case that it wiped our
memory of a previous episode of,
of human civilization that right at
the epicenter of this cataclysm was a
civilization that we would regard
as advanced, not as simple hunter,
gather a civilization which was utterly
wiped out in this cataclysmic event.
And I should say for anyone who's
really fascinated right now,
please maybe pause and go listen to
the one that the two that you did with
Randall Carlson. Yeah. We're really
goes into depth about the impact,
the evidence of these impacts,
the evidence of the very quick demise of
the Ice Age and what may have resulted
in all these floods that you read about
in the epic of Gilgamesh that you read
about a Noah's Ark and that all these
things are probably tales that have
stories that people pass down from
generation to generation that survived.
Yeah.
Because we now know that at that time
between twelve thousand eight hundred and
eleven thousand six hundred years ago,
truly global cataclysmic events
involving rapid rises in sea level, uh,
did occur. And suddenly the
worldwide tradition of, uh,
of a global flood stops being just a myth
and starts being a memory and account
of,
of real events.
It's been my privilege to work very
closely with rattle Carlson. He's a,
Randall is absolutely amazing.
He is a total genius.
He's also a gentle giant and such
a kind, generous, spirited person.
It's a joy to work with them and every
minute spent with him as an education,
I had the privilege of
traveling across the channel,
scab lands in Washington state with
Randall and seeing things through his eyes
really opened my eyes to the
scale of this disaster. You know,
you could look at these giant
boulders called glaciated erotics,
and they just look odd sitting
there in the landscape.
But when you really consider how they got
there that they got there in icebergs,
the size of oil tankers that were carried
on floods that were at least 500 up to
a thousand feet deep that we're
tearing through the channels. Scab,
lads literally ripping
the landscape apart.
Then the icebergs would ground on valley
sides. The flood waters would recede,
the icebergs would be left there, giant
icebergs, and as they melted away,
they revealed the rocks that had in chain
that we're caught up within them and
they're scattered all over the landscape.
And you look at that and you think
anything that was underneath that 12,800
years ago is gone completely.
There can't be anything left of it at all.
Utterly,
utterly destroyed.
And I would encourage people that are
interested in this to please watch the
youtube videos of it.
Cause Randall provides all sorts of
video and photographic evidence where you
can take a look at the landscape and you
get a perspective of how immense this
destruction was. Yeah, it's, it's
really, it's really important to,
to see that because it's easy enough
to talk about floods and, and,
and cataclysms.
But actually to see its effect on the
landscape directly is it has an emotional,
an emotional impact.
I felt,
I felt emotional traffic traveling
across the challenge, Gab lands,
really realizing that this was,
was the heart of an event that
changed the world completely.
And the evidence continues to build.
I have in America before I have not
gone over old ground that I went over in
magicians of the gods that we
covered in the various, um,
interviews and podcasts in which it's
really a good idea that people take a look
at.
But I,
what I have done is added
the new information published
since 2015 which further
supports the younger dryas impact
hypothesis and the notion that multiple
fragments of a giant comment,
uh,
hit the earth and created an
absolute global catastrophe.
So what was the motivation behind
creating this book America before?
It's a curious mixture of things.
I have been exploring the possibility
of a lost civilization for more than 25
years.
That was the essence of my book,
fingerprints of the Gods
that was published in 1995
that there has been a huge
forgot an episode in human history.
I continued to follow that in a series
of other books and by the time I got to
2002 when I published a book called
underworld that followed seven years of
scuba diving on continental shelves,
looking for structures that were submerged
by rising sea levels at the end of
the last ice age, I really felt I'd done
it. I felt I'd walk the walk, I put,
put out to the public a massive
body of information and I thought,
my role in this is over and I can breathe
a sigh of relief because it's hot in
this particular kitchen and
I can go do something else.
And I ended up writing a
book about psychedelics.
I ended up writing supernatural meetings
with the ancient teachers of mankind,
but the role of psychedelics in the
origins of the, of the human story.
But then new information started to
come out that touched on the lost
civilization idea. And I couldn't just
stand by and ignore that information.
That's why I published in
magicians of the Gods in 2015.
And then as I was researching that book,
I became aware of something I hadn't
realized before that there's a mass of new
information from the Americas,
specifically from the Americas,
which completely rewrites the story of
human history that the Americas, um,
have been misrepresented,
uh, for a very long time, uh,
by archaeology.
And archeologists will be annoyed with
me for saying that they have a way of
forgetting their own arrows, uh, of
saying, Oh, well, we knew that all along.
It wasn't,
it wasn't the case,
but the fact of the matter remains that
for best part of 50 years from the 1960s
through until about 2010,
American archeology was locked in a
dogma that they actually had a name for,
which was Clovis first, uh, that
they invented a name for a culture.
They call them the Clovis culture.
We don't know what they called themselves.
They were hunter gatherers.
They first appear in the
archeological record 13,400 years ago,
and they've banished from the
archeological record 12,600 years ago.
And for a very long time,
it was maintained adamantly that these
were the first Americans that no human
being touched the soil of the
Americas until 13,000, 400 years ago.
Just animals.
But no human beings present at all.
And any archeologist who
attempted to dispute that dogma,
and I use the word deliberately, there
should be no room for dogma in science,
but any archeologist who challenged that
would face severe problems with his or
her career,
they would be mocked and humiliated at
conferences like an archeologist called
Jackson Kumar's from, from Canada who
excavated in the, in the, in the Yukon,
humiliated at conferences, insulted,
accused of making stuff up. Uh,
their research funding would be withdrawn
basically to challenge Clovis first
was the end of your archaeological career.
So naturally,
very few archeologists wanted
to challenge Clovis first.
What was this gentleman in the Yukon?
What was this is called Jack sank.
Mars a and interestingly, the
Smithsonian just in 2017, uh,
did a big kind of mayor Kulpa
big admission about this,
that everybody had got things wrong,
that Jack's Hank Mars had been
ruined by the Clovis first lobby,
but he'd been right all along the site.
He excavated in the Yukon,
was re excavated in 2017 and every single
thing he said was correct even though
they had just sneered at him.
What was he?
He was activating in the 1980s in the
1990 [inaudible] he's still alive.
He's still alive. Yeah. Well I
think he's been indicated. You know,
and it's kind of,
it's kind of nice to be vindicated that
that there's almost a place in folk lore,
folk law for the, for the individual who
is scorned and humiliated, you know, by,
by others. But who turns out to
be, to be right. And he was right.
But my point about this is that what it
meant was since it was the dogma that
Clovis was first, that they oldest
dates were 13,400 years ago.
There seemed to be no logic to
archeologists in digging deeper.
You know how it is with
archaeology that the,
the upper levels are the youngest and
the deeper you go, the older it gets.
That's why we say Upper Paleolithic for
the late Ice Age and lower Paleolithic
for the late stone age and lower for the
older stone age and the feeling was no
need to dig below the Clovis layer
because we already know that there were no
human beings.
Then before that.
And then a few archeologists I mentioned
Jack Sank Mars. But uh, but, uh,
another is all good year
from the University of South
Carolina who excavated a
site called topper in South Carolina now.
Now topper is an incredibly rich
Clovis site. It's full of their tools,
their points.
They made these special special Flint
points that we used as arrowheads and
spear great Clovis site.
He finished excavating the Clovis level
and then he did something that was
supposed not to be done. He decided to
dig deeper and he carried on deeping down,
digging down.
And there was a,
a layer of about a meter and
a half of of barren soil.
And then beneath that
more human artifacts.
And they finally date those back
to more than 50,000 years ago.
And then in 2017,
published in nature by Tom Demorais,
who's the chief paleontologist at the
San Diego Natural History Museum, uh,
at a bunch of other very high level
paleontologists published in nature
magazine,
evidence for human presence in
North America 130,000 years ago.
Now this is really put the
cat amongst the pigeons. Now,
if humans were pressed North America
130,000 years ago and archeologists have
been telling us for 50 years that they
were only present from 13,000 years ago,
that's 10 times as long that we've had
humans in North America capable of doing
stuff and the archeological dogma has
prevented any search for what they were
doing until, until very recently. What
was the evidence from 130,000 years ago?
Okay, so what, it's not the, let me be
clear about this because, because this is,
this is something that is often
misrepresented in, in my views.
It is not the evidence for an advanced
civilization that we find a 130,000 years
ago in America. The evidence that we
find is evidence for human presence.
And what they were doing was very
much stone age stuff. It's a Mastodon,
it's a mastodon skeleton. Uh,
that was, that was excavated.
It was actually found by accident during
road construction near near San Diego.
And an archeologist was attached to the
road construction crew at immediately
stopped construction and they
investigated it thoroughly.
And what they found was so much dynamite
in the early 1990s when they found it,
that they decided not to publish at
the time because what they found was
evidence that those mastodon bones had
been cracked open by human beings using
tools and that the marrow
had been extracted,
that one Tusk could be left
standing upright in the ground.
And another had been left beside it,
that FEMA had a femur of the animal had
been taken away completely from the site.
Uh,
and there was assemblages of,
of instruments that we use
to smash and break the bones.
And the conclusion of the team was that
only one kind of creature could have
done that work using tools on a mastodon.
And that's human beings.
That's classic,
classic human behavior.
So this sets the goalposts
in a totally different place.
Suddenly we have to consider that
humans have been in for 130,000 years.
We already know that a dogmatic approach
of archeology has rather refused to
look at anything older
than 13,000 years ago.
And what it does is it generates an engine
of demand that we need to be looking
at those missing hundred thousand plus
years. We need to be looking at it hard.
Of course,
the immediate reaction has not been to
go looking for stuff in the other hundred
thousand years. Most archeologists have
responded by saying, this is impossible.
It can't be.
It can't be so,
but that's precisely what
they said to Jack Sank Mars,
who said that humans were in bluefish
caves in the Yukon 25,000 years ago,
and it's precisely what they said to
our Goodyear who said humans had been at
topper 50,000 years ago and they were
both right and I believe that Tom Demorais
and his team,
you don't get a big article published
in nature unless it's already pretty
solidly based and pretty much peer
reviews. It has produced a reaction.
I would be wrong to say that
it's universally accepted.
It's very much challenged. That is
intriguing. What is the challenge?
The challenge fundamentally comes from
we archeologists know that there were no
human beings in the Americas that
far back. To put it in perspective.
It's about 60,000 years before the first
evidence of human beings in Europe. Uh,
it's about 60,000 years before the first
evidence of human beings in Australia.
And this is just evidence of
the first human beings. Yes,
we have to point out how
difficult it is to find evidence.
Extremely difficult to find.
You know,
sometimes we imagined that archeologists
are working with masses of skeletal
material low. They're not, then
they're not. I mean the whole,
this is one of the ironies,
the whole Clovis first dogma,
you would think that they had
masses of material to work with.
They did have the tools, but in
terms of skeletal remains, just one,
just one single skeletal remains from one
of the things that Michael Shermer had
sent me,
was this a dispute that perhaps the
bones had been cracked open by the
excavation material?
Yeah. Excabation machines.
I saw Michael's email email last night
and I appreciate that Michael wants to
continue to engage with this subject
and that's his job. He's a pro.
He's a professional skeptic and it's
his, his role to do so. But what he,
what he misses that it's true that
a new paper has been published,
which raises questions over the,
uh,
what's called the Cerruti Mastodon site,
which is the site that Tom Demorais
at San Diego Natural History Museum
excavated.
And what's interesting since I can,
since Michael took the trouble to
write the questions, can I just, sure.
Can I just read you something that
I responded to them this? Sure.
Which is the microphone. Those, yeah.
Yeah. Basic. Basically this, this,
this paper was in no way a refutation
of the original paper in nature.
As a matter of fact,
the gentleman who wrote that paper
never even looked at the archaeological
remains that are in the now in the
San Diego Natural History Museum.
Um, what it is, what he
based it on, his reference,
I'm quoting from the
abstract of the paper itself,
reference to a freeway right of
way map and construction plans,
contemporary road building practices and
work site photographs available on the
Internet. In other words,
the site was not visited.
They simply looked at
secondary references.
They did not look at the archeological
material and they ignored the entire
argument of Tom Demmer and his colleagues
who had already addressed that issue.
They didn't look at the bones, they
did not look at the bones. When you,
when you break a fresh bone,
it has a characteristic kind of spiral
fracture that does not happen when you
break a fossilized bone.
And Tom Debray and his team specifically
ruled out road making machinery as
responsible for this breaking pattern
because they actually carried out
experiments on a modern elephants,
deceased elephants,
and they broke their bones.
And the kind of fracture that you get
in a fresh green bone is completely
different from the kind of Fletcher you
get in a, in a, in a fossilized bone.
So unfortunately this paper pays,
pays no attention to that.
It just looks at road plans and
says there was roadwork there.
It must have been done by roadwork. I
think it's very sloppy, very weak, and a,
it's certainly not the answer.
We can expect ongoing debate and that is,
that is healthy.
But this is not a strong case at all.
So this points to the first evidence
that we found and is there any effort
underway to try to uncover more evidence
from a similar 12 I'm going to cite to
Tom. Tom Decorated the chief
paleontologist San Diego
Natural History Museum.
That's what he would like to see.
He makes the point to be I interview him.
I said, I spent a day with him
that actually steam museum.
He was very generous with his time.
I did an extended interview and I quote
from it in in America before and his
wish is that archeologists,
instead of spending all that time trying
to find ways to dismiss and get rid of
his findings,
his wishes that they would spend a little
bit at that time looking at deposits
older than 13,400 years and even being
willing to go back as far as 130,000
years. That's, that's would be
a proper scientific response.
Here is a third body of work put forward
by a very senior group of scientists
who hesitated before they published it.
They had the information
back in the 1990s,
but it wasn't until refined dating
techniques later than in the 21st century
that they finally were sure what they
had and that they published it in nature
in 2017. It's a, it's, it's a,
it's an important study. Um,
and I think what's going to happen
is that we're going to find much more
evidence of a very ancient human
presence in the America America's,
and that's what Tom Demorais thinks
as well. Um, and as he points out,
if we don't look,
then we're never going to find,
if we allow dogma to stop
us looking and saying, well,
it's impossible that humans were
in the Americas 130,000 years ago,
so we won't bother to look what a
failure of science that is. And, and,
and to spend all the time instead of
trying to get rid of the evidence that
doesn't fit the current paradigm.
It's so fascinating that
just as fortuitous discovery
during a construction site
could change the way
people perceive things.
And you just got to wonder how
much of that stuff is. And I mean,
how deep did they have to go to find
these mastodon bones? So this is a,
this is a road cut that's being made.
So those would be,
does it be pretty deep down 10,
15 feet down the,
the greater is going through it and,
and flattening them.
It varies from place to place
depending on on soil deposition,
the stratification, the stratification
of the soil. But what the key,
the key point is that what you need
to do is go deeper than 13,000,
400 years ago and you need to do so with
dedication and vigor and with some kind
of funding. And at the moment
archeology doesn't, uh,
doesn't see the point of that.
If the paper in nature by
Tom Demorais was alone,
if there were nothing else than that,
uh,
I wouldn't place so much trust in it.
But I've spent a lot of time during
the researching of this book with
archeologists who dig, dig, dig, dig,
dig deeper.
And what those archeologists all confirm
is that there have been human beings in
the Americas for tens
of thousands of years.
And it's not surprising that that can
be pushed back to 130,000 years ago.
Because part of the argument about the
peopling of the Americas has to do with a
place that we now call the Bering
straits between Alaska and Siberia,
which during the Ice Age,
where at times a land bridge,
they were exposed because of,
because of low at sea levels,
but migrants who crossed that land
bridge from Siberia on many occasions,
over periods of tens of thousands of years
would find themselves confronted then
by the North American ice cap,
which oddly wasn't at the tip of Alaska,
but began further in. So there was
living space in a bit of Alaska,
but you couldn't get through
the ice mountains. These,
these literally ice mountains to two
miles deep covering the whole of North
America and preventing access
to the unglazed created, uh,
parts of America.
The thing is that what happened
around 13,400 years ago,
there had been a period of global warming
and the ice sheets began to melt and a
corridor opened up between what's called
the Cordillera and ice sheet and the
Laurentide ice sheet,
the two major ice keeps in North America
and it's thought that the migration
came through that corridor.
Well,
the thing is that exactly the same thing
happened between 140,000 years ago and
120,000 years ago there was
an episode of global warming,
an ice free corridor opened up and the
same opportunity to enter the Americas
was there at that period than
it was at the later period.
And Tom Demaris point and mine is that
we have to pay much more attention to
that earlier period. And that's really
why I've gone ahead and uh, and,
and written this book is to try to
put before a broad general audience,
hopefully in, in language that, that,
that makes sense and an assembly of all
the latest information that casts doubt
on the story we've been told.
Because my goodness,
if archaeology is wrong about the story
of the peopling of the Americas, if
it's radically wrong as
it now appears to be,
then our whole understanding
of human history has to change.
It's not just the history of the Americas,
it's the history of the entire world.
It has been an absolute article of faith
amongst archeologists that civilization
began in the old world. And, uh, indeed,
I have a,
I have a book in my library called
history begins at summa and it's by Samuel
Noah Kramer are very renowned
archaeologist. Uh, and it's a,
it's a good book actually.
But the argument is that this is where
civilization began in the culture that we
call the Sumerians in Mesopotamia
between the Tigris and Euphrates rivers,
and that it began about 6,000 years ago.
And that civilization is
entirely an invention of the
old world that has nothing
to do with the new world at all because
of the new world was populated so late.
This has,
this has been the,
this has been the argument and this
is the argument that now radically and
suddenly begins to change that the
Americas, this enormous landmass resorts,
rich, bountiful in, in every
way south of Minnesota,
south of the ice cap, vast land
areas that are, that are bad.
We'll get into South America, Central
America, South America, the Amazon,
just huge areas of land that were very,
very offered.
Great potential for human occupation.
Dogma has said there were no humans there.
Now the first bits of evidence are coming
out that says there were humans there,
and if that's the case,
then we must consider the possibility
that the story of civilization might've
begun in the Americas,
not in the old world at all.
It might be a new world invention,
not another word, adventure.
Some of the more fascinating pieces of
evidence in South America have come out
recently about these channels and pathways
that they've found in the Amazon that
could not have been created any other way,
but by humans creating irrigation,
humans creating the, like,
it appears like grids,
like a city grid.
Definitely the Amazon is
a colossal mystery and a,
it's one of the subjects that I explore
in depth in America before. First of all,
to give some basic figures.
The Amazon basin is huge.
The Amazon Basin is 7 million square
kilometers in area and within it,
five and a half million square kilometers,
uh,
remains almost entirely
unstudied by archeologists.
And that's the five and a half million
square kilometers that is still covered
by dense rain forest.
And to put that into perspective,
five and a half million square kilometers
is the size of the entire Indian
subcontinent. So it's like saying
we've done world archeology,
but we've just ignored India. You
know, we've done world archeology,
but we just ignored the Amazon is the
same at the same migrant five and a half
million square kilometers. The
view was, again, there was a dogma,
there was a preconception, human beings
couldn't have flourished in the Amazon.
It's a, it's not a resource rich
area. The soils are poor. Um,
it's a difficult area, challenging to
get to very far from the Bering straits.
So the view was that humans hadn't
entered the Amazon until about a thousand
years ago. And then
gradually, little by little,
that view has begun to change and it's
begun to change because of the tragic
clearances of the Amazon.
Because the Amazon rain
forest is literally being
cut down and turned into soya
bean farms and cattle ranchers.
And in that cutting down process has
emerged things that shouldn't be there at
all. Uh, for example,
evidence that large cities flourished
in the Amazon enormous cities,
which were larger than the,
there was a Spanish explorer who went
down the Amazon River system in 1541 to
1542,
he was the first European to cross the
entire length of South America from west
to east. Uh, along the Amazon, he
reported seeing incredible cities,
advanced arts and craft, millions
of people, a thriving culture. Uh,
and a hundred years later when
other Europeans got into the Amazon,
they couldn't find these cities. So
they said, oh, Francisco, Arianna,
that was his name, made it all up.
It was just a, it was just a fantasy.
And then in the last decade is the
clearances at the Amazon have proceeded.
We've begun to see the
traces of those cities.
What happened was that the Spaniards
brought small pox into the Amazon.
Smallpox devastated the local population
because there was no immunity to it.
There was a massive die off. The
cities were deserted within a 50 years.
They were completely overgrown by the
jungle and that's why they were not seen
by the explorers who came
in a hundred years later.
But now the youngest being cleared,
those cities are emerging and we can
say that, uh, a city like London,
which had a population of roughly
50,000 in the 16th century,
there were cities of that
size all over the Amazon.
Huge numbers of them and possible total
population of the Amazon that exceeded
20 million people. Yes, 20 billion.
This is the latest evidence from the
Amazon. And then you ask yourself,
how did they do that? How did they
feed 20 million people in the Amazon?
Because it's a fact
rainforest soils are poor.
It's one of the reasons these soya
bean farms are really stupid idea.
Because once you clear the rain forest,
the land is largely unfair tile and you
can't grow stuff on it for very long.
So how did they feed all these people?
The answer was they invented a
soil and that soil has a name,
it's called Tara Prater.
Archeologists referred to it as Amazonian
dark earth or Amazonian black earth.
It's a manmade soil.
It's thousands of years old.
It's full of microbes that are
not found in a joining soil.
It's based around bio char.
Uh,
and you can take a handful of 8,000 year
old terra prater and you can add it to
barren soil and that soil
will instantly become fertile.
It's highly sought after in the Amazon
and it explains how they fed these people.
There was silence in the
atmosphere to create this, well,
this is something that's not understood.
It's still not understood
by social experts to this
day is to how that was done.
But it's one of many intriguing evidences,
pieces of evidence of
much higher a development
in the Amazon that it has been given
credit for and have a kind of science in
the, Jamie's got an image of
it up there. So this is a,
this is Tara. Yeah. Yeah. Wow.
Exactly. So was that done by burns? Did
these controlled burns? They did. They,
one way that it was achieved was,
uh, was to do wet burning, um,
of middens.
They would be,
they would be burned and smolder
they wouldn't bend fiercely,
which just produces charcoal. They would,
they would burn and smolder. Um, and,
and that by what is called
biochar would result.
And that's part of the
fertility of the soil.
But the mystery is the
microbial content of the soil,
which is completely different from
the microbes in neighboring soils.
And that's remains unexplained. So do
they, what are the theories? Composting,
some sort of advanced compost as some
sort of, some sort of advanced composting.
But again,
what has not been explained is that Ma
is the Mike microbial content of these
soils. So they're there, first of all
is an issue of how, uh, two things,
how large populations get fed in the
Amazon and evidence that there was a
culture in the Amazon that was capable
of manipulating the environment in such a
way that it could support
large populations with the
invention of terror. Prater.
Secondly,
new evidence previously not recognized.
The Amazon is basically a garden.
The Amazon is a manmade rain forest.
Uh, there are certain trees like Brazil
nut trees or the ice cream bean tree,
which are food crops, which are very,
very valuable. And they dominate the,
uh, the, the tree regime
in the Amazon. They,
what's what's referred to as hypo
dominant species. In other words,
people living in the Amazon over thousands
of years selected certain trees which
they then cultivated and grew.
So the whole thing is not simply a wild,
pristine rainforest.
It's a very ancient manmade environment
and emerging from that manmade
environment as well as evidence of
large cities, large populations,
and this mysterious dark earth
are huge geometrical structures.
Um,
and again,
I go into this at length in America
before because I love this mystery.
We have in the UK structures
that are called hinges. Um,
I live in the city of bath and about
30 miles away there's a beautiful site
called aviary and another more
famous site called Stonehenge.
And what a Henge is,
is a ditch which has been dug deep and
then an embankment has been pushed up
outside the ditch.
When people first saw these structures,
they wondered if they'd
been built for defense,
but then it became obvious they
hadn't been built for defense.
Because if you want to create a moat,
you put it outside your embankment,
not insight. You're in Bankman.
So in a hand is an earthwork,
which consists of a deep moat with a
large embankment outside it and it can be
circular, it can be square, and in
the UK and other parts of Europe,
it often contains stone circles,
megalithic stone circles as well.
But the Henge itself is
entirely an earthwork.
What we find in the Amazon are thousands
of that are now beginning to emerge
from the cleared area of the jungle and
others that have been identified for the
first time with Lidar, lidar technology
is being employed in the Amazon.
It's nondestructive. You can see what's
under the trees. What does lidar,
light imaging and detective radar, they
mounts laser beams down into the jungle.
This whole pattern of them,
you need helicopters and they they,
but it doesn't damage the rain forest
and you can strip away and see what's,
see what's there.
And if this is too much of that diversion.
Let me give you the example of Guatemala.
Guatemala is a small country,
if I remember correctly.
It's not much more than a hundred
thousand square kilometers in size. Um,
it is filled with intriguing Mayan ruins.
Everybody has heard of teacol.
Carl,
what archaeal just didn't know was that
literally within walking distance of
teacol surrounding that whole area,
we're more than 60,000 structures
that they hadn't identified.
And these have all been identified by
lidar in a country that's just a hundred
thousand kilometers in area.
So you'll have to ask yourself in that
five and a half million square kilometers
of the Amazon, if lidar technology
could be applied comprehensively,
what would we find beneath there?
And the evidence already is extremely
tempting and extremely tantalizing and I'm
intrigued by these huge
geometrical figures, uh,
which involve primarily a circles and
squares and they are classic hinges in the
sense that they are deep ditches
surrounded by huge embankments.
They're extremely geometrical.
For example,
you can find an octagon surrounding a
square at a place called Jacko sa in the
Amazon. You can find a square
perfectly in closing a circle.
Now that is an exercise called squaring
the circle that are archaea are our
academics have given to the Greeks.
They said the Greeks were the first
person people who perform that exercise.
But now we find in dated sites in the
Amazon that this was being done in the
Amazon long before the Greeks.
What are the dates?
The earliest dates that have been found
in these sites now are about three and a
half thousand years old,
about three and a half thousand years old.
But the evidence is that the
sites have been constantly remade.
And what intrigues me is what remains
in that five and a half million square
kilometers that has not been
investigated yet. We are just,
I think looking at the edges of a mystery,
the archeologists involved to a mainly
from Finland and also from Brazil feel
the same.
They're,
their estimate is that there are thousands
of these structures remaining in the
jungle and they're open as to how old
they may ultimately prove to be the
investigation needs to be done.
But what's fascinating about them is this
very powerful geometry and astronomy.
So a number of the sites are perfectly
aligned to true north, true south,
true east and true West.
I'm not talking about magnetic north,
I'm talking about true
astronomical Doulas to do that.
There's only one way to do it. And
that's with, uh, with astronomy.
So that tells us that astronomers
were at work in the Amazon.
The geometry is very
complex and very precise.
That tells us that people with geometrical
skills, we're working in the Amazon.
And thirdly, the scale of the
sites of hundreds of meters,
gigantic earthworks on the
scale of hundreds of meters,
tells us that this was highly organized
project that was undertaken on a very
large scale by very
large numbers of people.
It's a wonderful mystery and
it deserves much further,
much further attention. And I'm,
I'm, yeah, that's Jacko sa. Exactly.
The squares squaring the circle,
so you can see the outside embankment
and then inside it is the square ditch.
And then there's another embankment inside
that and a circle and a circle inside
there.
Crazy. They made a road right through
that modern road. Yeah. You know, because,
because there's no respect for,
there's no respect for the ancient,
for the ancient world, unfortunately. And
there's another one look at that. Wow,
that's incredible.
So that there are thousands of the sound,
the stuff that they found in the Amazon.
What imaging technology
were they using to find
all initially,
initially it was entirely found because
areas of the rain forest had been
cleared. Economic interests said,
we want to make a cattle ranch here,
or we want to make a soy bean farm here.
So we're just gonna clear the rain forest.
In the process of
clearing the rain forest,
they start discovering these earthworks
that had previously been completely
overgrown by the jungle. Then
the next step was to say, uh,
what can we, what can we do
to find out more about this?
Obviously they don't want
to destroy more jungle.
And Luckily we have a technology which
is, which is Lidar, as I mentioned,
which uses radar and using lidar.
They'd been identified,
able to identify many more of these sites
and then to get to the sites without
destroying the jungle and
to begin excavations on them
and to find that they go
back in the cases of the ones
that have been explored so far,
at least 3000 years. Uh, this
is an intriguing development,
completely unexplained in our
understanding of the Amazon.
And what it suggests is a heritage
of extremely ancient knowledge.
You don't wake up one
morning and you know,
create a perfectly geometrical square
or circular earthwork that's perfectly
aligned to true north, south, east
and West on an enormous scale.
That has to be a background to that.
That'd be a reason for doing it.
And the evidence is none of these sites
were lived in. There's no habitation,
a refuse found in them
whatsoever. They were, they,
we don't know what they were used for.
I make the case in America before that
they're connected to a system of ideas
which has found all around the world,
which,
which has to do with
death and the afterlife,
destiny of the soul. Uh, and I
go into the issue of Iowasca,
uh, in, in this book because
I, first of all, I was,
is itself another example of
Amazonian Science. Um, as you and I,
and many of the listeners
and viewers know, uh,
the active ingredient of Iowasca
is DMT dimethyltryptamine,
but dimethyltryptamine is not
normally accessible through the gut.
We have to smoke it or,
or vape it to get that rocket ship to
the other side of reality and journey.
Last Swat 10, 12 minutes. Not
much more than that. Sometimes,
sometimes quite a lot less.
What [inaudible] does is it makes
DMT available through the gut.
The reason it's not available through
the gutters because of an enzyme in the
gut called monoamine oxidase.
And that switches off DMT on contact,
the Iowasca Vine,
which is one of the two
ingredients of the IOWASCA brew.
The other ingredient is
leaves that contain DMT.
The IOWASCA vine contains a
monoamine oxidase inhibitor,
which switches off the enzyme in the
gut and allows the DMT to be accessed to
orally,
which produces a rather different journey
from the smoked or vaped DMT trip.
It's a much longer journey.
It's four or five hours.
It allows you to integrate and to,
and to interrelate with the strange
landscapes in which you find yourself
amongst and the entities
that you encounter.
I'm not making any claims about the
reality status of those entities,
but what I am saying,
and it's a fact,
is that people who work with DMT and
Iowaska do encounter what they construe to
be entities, uh, who, who
communicate with them intelligently.
So somebody in the Amazon out of 150,000
different species of plants and trees
selected too that are not psychoactive
on their own. But when put together,
create an extraordinary visionary brew,
uh,
Iowasca means the vine of the dead
and what it's connected to, uh,
in South American religious
and spiritual thinking, uh,
is what happens to us
when we die. Uh, and, uh,
the Takano who are an Amazonian people
who work regularly with Iowa Ska,
I mean the Tucano actually will give a
teaspoon full of Iowa Asca to a newborn
infant.
They feel I was so important that there
is a hidden realm around us which we are
not normally aware of and
we need to be aware of it.
And I ask it as an important part of that.
In there I'll ask a journeys,
the Takano schamens experience visions
and they will then come back to an ilit
normal problem solving
state of consciousness.
And they will paint and depict their
visions. And what's intriguing,
and I go into it in the book,
is the quite a number of the Takano
paintings of the other world,
of the afterlife realm of the entrance
to the other world are geometrical and
they look exactly like the geog lifts.
So I'm beginning to wonder whether these
geoglyphs we're part of a system of
spiritual ideas concerning what happens
to us after death and what we need to do
in this life to ensure a beneficial
outcome. And oddly enough,
that same system of ideas is found in
the Mississippi valley, in the Amazon.
It involves,
uh,
particularly Iowasca and the belief that
the Iowaska journey takes you to the
afterlife realm and a journey along the
milky way in the Mississippi Valley.
Um, the mound builder sites up
and down the Mississippi Valley,
particularly Mountville in Alabama,
exactly the same system of religious
ideas associated with geometrical
constructions that on death the soul,
they're very specific ascends to the
constellation of Orion transits from the
constellation of Orion to the Milky Way
makes a journey along the Milky Way,
which they call the path of souls and
encounters challenges and ordeals where
the soul must account for
the life that it has lived.
Then we got to Egypt and what do we find?
The same system of ideas.
The soul must rise up to
the constellation of Orion.
There's a narrow shaft cut through the
southern side of the Great Pyramid of
Giza, which targets directly the lowest
of the three stars of Orion's belt,
widely the accepted as a
star shaft or a sole shaft.
The soul would rise up through that shaft,
get to the Constellation of Orion,
which stands by the
banks of the Milky Way,
and would then transit to the Milky Way,
which the ancient Egyptians
called the winding waterway.
And it would make a journey along the
milky way where it would be confronted by
challenges and ordeals very similar idea
to the Takano very similar idea to the
Mississippi valley as far as we know.
None of these cultures were in
contact with one another. Either.
We're dealing with a huge,
unbelievable,
extraordinarily detailed coincidence
involving architecture and ideas.
Or we're looking at the legacy that
was inherited in all of these different
places from a remote common ancestor.
And,
and I believe that that's
what we're looking at.
What do we think the people from the
ancient Mississippi Valley, that culture,
what do we think they were using if they
weren't using Iowasca or do we think
that that's what they were
using? Well, that's, that's,
that's an interesting question.
Whether,
whether visionary substances are the
only way to get into altered states of
consciousness. And, and, uh, I
would say they are definitely not a,
of course there are visionary
substances which are,
which are used in native American
vision, vision quests. I've, I've,
I've had the privilege of Payoti ceremony,
uh,
with the native American church. I've
never done that. What does that look like?
I loved it actually. I thought, I
thought it was, I thought it was amazing.
It doesn't overpower you in the way that
DMT or Iowaska does. Uh, it's, it's,
it's much gentler.
It's much more,
you feel much more integrated and
connected with, with, with nature.
Your thought processes are
quite, quite clear. It felt,
it felt just like a very
beautiful and healing experience.
And I loved the ceremony that I'm in.
I'm inside a teepee with,
with 30 or 40 other people and that there,
there are specific roles that are assigned
to those different individuals. One,
we'll keep the door,
another will be responsible for the fire,
which is a work of art in itself. Just
gazing into that fire and the glowing,
the glowing embers is enough to induce
an altered state of consciousness on its
own. Incredible drumming, which,
which drives your state of consciousness
into a kind of peak peak experience.
This is a technology for accessing other
levels of experience and other levels
of reality.
And it's clear that the native Americans
had a number of advanced technologies
in this area. The Sun dance doesn't
use a substance, but it uses austerity.
It uses pain to drive an
altered state of consciousness.
The objective in every case seems to be,
let's just for a while,
get ourselves out of the narrow,
rigid frame of the Ilit problem solving
state of consciousness. We all need that.
It's incredibly useful.
Hunter gatherer is needed just as
much as people in cities need it,
but it's not the only state of
consciousness available to human beings.
And maybe that's one of the big mistakes
that we're making in our culture, um,
and was not made, uh, in,
in shamanistic societies
that that is a really
interesting breakdown that
maybe that is one of the big
mistakes we're making in our culture
when people point to the problems that we
have in this country.
One of the problems we have is our
inability to connect with each other or to
recognize that we're all sharing this
space and time together and instead
wanting to uphold our own religious or
ideological ideas as being the only one
way to get going. Yeah. The
only one way to get through.
And one of the things that I've found,
the psychedelic experiences,
it really makes ideologies seem,
uh,
if not preposterous,
at the very least insignificant in
comparison to human experiences.
The experience of,
of comradery and friendship and love it,
you realize like, oh,
this is what's important.
This is really about not enforcing your
ideas are pushing them on other people
and forcing people to behave
the way you behave. But instead
I'm thinking about religious ideas,
which caused so much division,
so much chaos, so much
hatred, so much fear, so much
suspicion in the world today.
Is it really what we want to do as human
beings simply to accept a package of
ideas that were believed in by our
ancestors to accept them whole without
question as absolute fact,
which we regard as such a Thursday to
fact that in some cases we're willing to
be deeply unpleasant to people who hold
different views or perhaps even killed
him. Uh, we've had this, you know,
this recent event in, in, in,
in Sri Lanka or primarily a religiously
motivated terrorist event that happens.
It happens all over the world that people
feel so convinced that the inherited
package of ideas that they had nothing
to do with creating and that they have
never questioned. They're so
convinced that those ideas are right,
that in extreme cases they are actually
prepared to kill other human beings who
hold different ideas.
There are they so insecure in their own,
in their own beliefs that that they're
prepared to go to that level of actually
murdering another human being.
Who else?
They're so threatened by the other
beliefs that other human beings hold.
So it's an abnegation of our
responsibility as human beings,
we should be questioning things.
We should not be accepting
packages of ideas intact,
fully formed and using them to drive
the way we behave towards one another.
That was part of the human story, but
we need to move on from that. I mean,
it's a very dangerous situation in a very
complex modern world with billions of
human beings on the planet to have these
kinds of energy's being generated were
certain groups of people are saying,
we are absolutely right and you are
absolutely wrong. We are superior.
You are inferior. This is a very,
very dangerous path that we're,
that we're on and it needs to be changed.
Personally,
I know this is not a comment that
will go down well with many people,
but I am strongly opposed to nationalism.
I don't,
I don't see any virtue in nationalism.
It is an accident of birth,
which nation you were born in. It was
nothing that you did for your own merit.
You didn't earn that you were born by
accident in, in a particular nation.
Why should we automatically feel the
other people who were born by accident in
that particular nation has
something special in common with us?
And that we together are a group who are
much more important than other groups
of people. I've been privileged to spend
my life traveling around the world,
living with communities all over,
over the world.
And one thing that really
comes across to me strongly,
it should be a cliche and yet it's not,
is that we are all one family.
That humans are intimately
interconnected all around the world.
That you can go to the remotest area
of the Amazon jungle and find the same
hopes, the same fears, the same dreams
that we have in industrialized cities,
shared by the hunter gatherers in
the, in, in the middle of the Amazon.
So our similarities as human beings and
what we share in common at the emotional
level and the level of love and at the
level of heart are far more important
than our differences that are defined
by the nation or the political group in
which we in which we grew up in. And when
I, when I say I'm against nationalism,
I need also to make
clear that does not mean,
and I hope I'm not taking out of context
by others who are listening to this.
That does not mean I'm in favor of
world government. I detest governments.
That's another thing we need to grow out
of. We don't need governments anymore.
If we have them, they should have
a very minimal role in our society.
I think it's possible for the human race
to relate as one family without leaders
and governments who are exploiting
the worst aspects of our character,
the lowest common
denominator of our society.
Deliberately encouraging theaters and
hatreds and suspicions what responsible
leaders should be doing is encouraging
love and unity and their failure to do
that,
in my view,
disqualifies them from the
leadership role entirely.
And that's why I've
often said I would not,
I would like to see a situation in which
no head of state can be appointed to
that position unless he or she has
first had 12 sessions of Iowasca.
That would be the condition.
Don't even bother applying for the job
if you haven't done that and we have to
be there where you have
it and we have to be,
we want to see that you're drinking
every drop and we wanted an experience
Sharman presence who's really
going to guide you through the,
through the journey.
And I suspect that that would be a
transformative experience for many of our
political class and that they would start
to question why they do what they do,
why they exploit fears in order
to magnify their own position.
They'd start to question that and to
wonder about a different destiny for
humanity. But that's a dream. I
guess it's not going to happen.
Very, very, very well said
and I couldn't agree more.
My hope is that what you were saying and
what we were discussing earlier about
how the Internet is sort of a roaded
our faith in many institutions
as being the only or the primary source
of knowledge that I hope that that takes
place globally in terms of the
way we view government. Yeah.
And that we do that your idea of like,
I love what America stands for and what
America stands for is kind of a nation.
That's where people go to,
you know,
this is one of the more insidious problems
with this idea of building walls and
keeping people out and making it
incredibly difficult to get here.
The reason why I'm here is cause it
was pretty easy to get here. Yeah.
That's why I'm here. That's,
that's the essence of America.
A free and open society come here and do
better. That's the whole idea behind it.
I would hope that this
idea of being able to just,
if you want to do manner that
you can anywhere in the world,
this could eventually spread
out. Yes. This is my hope.
I believe it can spread out and, and um,
you know, I see many signs of hope, uh,
in, in, in America. Uh, America
has become a big part of my life,
not just because I wrote this book,
but because I have children
who are now living in America.
I have a son and daughter in law who,
who live in La.
I have another son and daughter in
law who live in Boston. America. I'm,
I'm British.
But America has become a very central
part of my life and it's a fascinating and
amazing country and it's been my privilege
to travel thousands of miles across
America, across many, many,
many different states. And I,
I love this country. It's a,
it's a,
it's an amazing place.
Only in America could we see happening.
What has happened with cannabis,
you know, then the fact that at a,
at a local level, individuals have
got together, mobilized petitions,
organized votes, and changed
the law, change the law. Diff,
literally stuck a finger up at
central government and said, fuck off.
This is none of your business.
What I do with my consciousness in the
inner sanctum of my own life is not the
business of the state. That's
a very American feeling. It's,
it's something that you don't find often
in other countries where the state is
granted much more power and much more
authority than it perhaps should be.
Americans are naturally questioning
of government authority and that has,
that is what has led to the,
uh,
legalization increasingly
legalization of cannabis,
which is going to change
the world in lots of ways.
But then ironically at the same time,
see the thing about democracies is
that in order to get things done in a
democracy, you need to persuade
people of your point of view.
So information becomes very important in,
in democracies and
information can be abused,
people can be misled with information.
They can be told that what they're
receiving is the truth, whereas in fact,
it's not the truth.
And you can end up with a
kind of dictatorship that
the people have given their
ascent to on the basis of, of
false information. And frankly,
I'd rather have a real dictatorship,
which is, which is out in the open.
And clear rather than one that has
been subtly manipulated into through
manipulating
the, the, the, the views
of the, of, of the voters.
But I am and remain enormously
encouraged by America.
It may seem like a trivial issue,
but the fact that state by state
cannabis is being legalized and that is
resulting from a grass roots movement
that this enormous change has been made
either. It's ironic, it's strange
that at the federal level,
even though what eight states now
totally legal for recreational, uh, 23,
24 states, legal, legal for medical
use, that at the federal level,
it's still a schedule one controlled,
controlled drug.
This is a huge state of dissonance that
exists in America is going to have to
put it right. What it says to me
is that people can change things,
people can get together at the local
level and they can make a better world
because there's no doubt that the cannabis
laws were vicious and wrong and cruel
and evil and ruined people's lives for,
for decades.
And it's people who've changed that
it's not government has changed,
that it's the people at the grassroots
level in America is a country where that
can happen. And I, I,
I remain encouraged about about the role
of the American people while often in
despair about the role
of the American state.
Yeah, I'm encouraged
as well. And you know,
it's interesting Ben and Jerry
release something yesterday,
which is really our on four 20,
I should say,
which was talking about the drug laws
in this country and talking about how
many, it's really, really
opening this, the, uh,
the idea of like how unjust these laws
were and how many of these laws targeted
people of color and how many people who
are white people have profited off of
this and how many people are still in
jail for crimes that they committed,
you know,
air quote crimes that are no longer crime,
that are no longer crime and this
is ridiculous. And then these,
these records should be expunged.
I see that California has made
some steps in that direction.
There has been some expunging of course.
Well, we can only hope that also what,
what opens up next is silicide been, is
now going to be on the ballot. Absolutely.
And when that opens up, I mean what you
really think marijuana is a gateway drug?
Well guess what it is if
silicide been gets in. Yes.
Because silicide can legitimately
changed the world. It really,
I mean I think marijuana can change
the world and I really do think that
cannabis has changing people's perceptions
and making people more calm and
friendly and yeah, and even the,
what they talk about with paranoia.
I welcome that.
And the reason why welcome that is I
think people are entirely too cocky. The,
the life we live as bizarre as you
could ever imagine a book and we're just
accustomed to it because it's
our day to day for granted.
Marijuana removes those blinders and it
really makes you understand that this is
a strange, strange life. And these,
a lot of these pitfalls and problems that
we have in our society are due to fear
and they're due to ignorance and their,
their due to this,
this lack of connection with each other.
And cannabis and many of
these other psychedelic drugs,
they encourage this connection
with each other, which is,
I think what we need need.
It's, it's, it's certainly
what we need and, and,
and it's an aberration in human culture
that we've created a society that
demonize these substances and that made
them illegal is it's a relatively recent
thing. It's really just the last, the
last hundred years. It's, uh, it's,
it's a tiny part of the human story and
yet we were so arrogant as a society
that we could set aside thousands of years
of human tradition and experience and
wisdom working with the plant medicines.
We just set it aside,
turn them into criminal substances
and say, we know everything. What a,
what a huge and stupid mistake that is,
um,
on cannabis as a quote
unquote gateway drug.
It absolutely is in this sense that the
legalization of cannabis is going to
open the doors to, as you, as you say,
to the legalization of, of psychedelics.
Because what's happening is that the
population is completely waking up to the
fact that they have been bullshitted
and lied to about cannabis for the best
part of a century.
And once that dawns on people,
the realization at a direct, personal
level, here's this herb I love.
I have been lied to,
systematically misinformed by
central government, uh, about this,
about this herb that leads to questioning
of everything that central government
does. And so in that sense, it is
a gateway to a questioning society.
The psychedelics are different
in that, in that Psilocybin, um,
actually does lead you to question stuff.
It leads you to really ask
questions about, about everything,
about your role in the world,
about you as a person,
about how you relate to other people and
about the whole system on this planet
and the beautiful,
gorgeous planet that we,
that we have and what we're doing to it.
That that also enters, enters awareness.
So it erodes confidence and authority.
And it also roads,
confidence and authority that doesn't
have experiences that you've experienced.
That's the part of the problem is that
these people that are holding people back
from these psychedelic
experiences, they've never had
them. They've never had it.
They don't even know
what they're rallying.
That coming to it from a place
of fear and prejudice, uh,
there's simply accepting stuff that they'd
been told without really thinking it
through [inaudible] and examining
it. And again, it's a failure of,
of what human beings should,
should be doing. We have to get,
we have to get rid of this fear and
ironically it's bad for them as well.
It's bad for the people that
are actually encouraging this,
these laws to be enforced.
Yes, it's bad for,
it's bad for the whole of the whole of
society because it is healthy for a,
for a society where adults
become self realized,
individuals where they make their own
responsible choices about their own lives,
where they don't say, oh, government
must make this choice for me.
That's the next step for humanity.
We start,
we need to start becoming our own leaders
and making our own choices and that
is, that is what's being revealed now that
we're getting to the skull beneath the
smile of the war on drugs.
We are realizing that it's part of a
big program of lying that has been about
keeping people's minds closed down,
not wanting free thinking.
I've made this point several times,
but our society is not against altered
states of consciousness as such.
Our society will allow big Pharma to
make billions of dollars with drugs that
alter consciousness like Ciroc,
satin, Prozac, antidepressants,
which in my opinion,
having had some experience of them are
amongst the most horrible drugs on the
planet. They are very
harmful, very dangerous drugs,
but they're completely legal and they're
encouraged with our system. Likewise,
alcohol, very dangerous
drug causes, fights,
causes drunk driving accidents,
leads to cirrhosis of the liver,
completely legal and open.
Uh,
society is not against altered
states of consciousness as such.
It's against particular kinds of altered
states of consciousness that lead to
questioning of the existing
control system. That's what's,
that's what's going on here, here,
here. Well said. And as you know,
I have my own story with, uh,
with, with cannabis. Well,
you and I had a moment.
We had a moment which was,
which was quite a life changing
moment for me because I,
if I may just rehearse a little
bit of this for the audience. Um,
in 2011, I had a series
of Iowasca sessions, uh,
in which it was shown to me that I was
using cannabis completely wrong, uh,
that it had become a dominant force
in my life, that it was making me,
you're speaking about paranoia.
And I agree with your paranoia is a,
is a useful thing if only to overcome it.
That it was making me paranoid that
it was making me suspicious that I
approached everybody around
me in a state of suspicion.
And I was shown this by Iowasca
and given a very strong message,
you need to quit cannabis.
What I didn't realize at the time is
that the problem was not cannabis.
The problem was me,
uh,
that I needed to fix those aspects of
myself before I could have a proper
relationship with cannabis.
So after that IOWASCA session,
having smoked cannabis for decades,
literally 16 hours a day,
seven days a week,
I quit.
I quit for three years and then
I'm on your show and we're sitting,
we're sitting opposite. But in others we
are now, and you asked me a question, um,
are you still off the cannabis
and that? And I say, well,
I'm thinking of dipping
my toes back in the water,
at which point you produce a
joint and we smoke it together.
First of all, after three years, your
tolerance is way down on cannabis.
So I got really stoned.
I did listen to that interview back in.
Somehow I held it together
together brilliantly.
You opened up and there was like a wave
of information came pouring out of you.
It was wonderful.
It was a liberation for me.
And what it said to me is it's
time to go back to cannabis,
but perhaps in a different way,
it doesn't it.
I need a different relationship
with his amazing medicine and,
and if I can forge that, if I can make
that different relationship happen,
then it can be a constructive
and positive part of my life.
And I can say definitely that that has
been the case and that's excellent.
And so it's all thanks to you,
Joe.
I probably would still be off cannabis
if it hadn't been for that joint. Well,
I think people can develop these patterns
of behavior that are destructive with
anything, whether it's with alcohol or
cannabis or sex or anything. People get,
they get in ruts. Yeah. You know, it
doesn't mean that the cannabis is bad.
It means that you are on a bad
mental path. Yes. You know? I mean,
I'm not encouraging it for everybody
because some people are genuinely,
biologically it doesn't jive
with them. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The fundamental thing is we as adult
human beings need to take responsibility
for our own lives and our own decisions.
And we need no Tom that responsibility
over to governmental institutions,
especially when it concerns something
as intimate and personal as our
consciousness. And, uh,
my view is the ancient world had the
right attitude to this kind of thing and
the modern world does not.
And that we can sit down and learn
a lot from the ancient world.
A lot of people ask me,
you know, handcuffed,
you've been arguing that there's a loss.
There's been a lost civilization in the,
in the, in the human story. But what,
what sort of civilization do you think it
was? Well, one of the things I think is,
was a civilization that use psychedelics.
I think it was a civilization that
emerged from shamanism but did not stay at
the hunter gatherer stage.
But that took the essence of shamanism
and integrated it into a very different
kind of civilization from our, uh,
which pursued things in different ways.
A lot of archeologists have said to me,
but we don't find any plastic
bottles from the ice age.
That means there was no
advanced civilization during
the Ice Age. Well hang on,
maybe an advanced civilization might
have decided never to get involved in
plastic in the first place.
Maybe they would have been a
clear choice not to make plastic.
Maybe they did things in
completely different ways.
Maybe they cultivated powers of the
human mind that we dismiss and regard as
completely, completely unimportant.
You know, Woo Woo. Yeah.
This is the thoughts about Egypt, correct?
It's about about Egypt and, and, and,
and about other things.
I mean the specific example I give is
above the king's chamber in the Great
Pyramid are five further chambers and
these chambers are rushed and floored with
granite beams that weigh about 70 tons
each and there are hundreds of them.
And these 70 ton granite beams,
which to put in context,
a 70 ton beam is equivalent in weight to
35 large SUV loves these 70 ton granite
beams have been elevated to a height
of more than 350 feet above the ground.
And carefully and precisely
placed in position.
It is very hard for archeologists
to explain how that was done.
Using purely leverage mechanical
advantage, you can say, oh,
and perhaps they built a ramp and and,
and hold the stones up the ramp.
But then you have to confront
basic laws of physics.
You can't hold a stone weighing tens of
tons up a slope that exceeds 10 degrees.
Then you start doing the calculation.
How long the ramp do I need with a 10
degree slope to get to 350 feet above the
ground? And the answer is you
need a fucking long round, which,
which should still be there because not
that it couldn't have been a sand ramp,
I would've collapsed under
the weight of those stones.
It had to be as massive
as the pyramid itself.
So this begins to seem like
an absurd idea. The, the,
the idea that is foisted on
us by archeology may be the
idea that they regard as
absurd, namely that psychic powers were
cultivated by ancient civilizations,
that they could use powers of the human
mind that we have allowed to lapse.
Maybe that idea deserves
further consideration. Um,
we have gone down a path of
leverage and mechanical advantage.
We used to relying on machines,
but we hear anecdotal reports of people
who have telekinetic powers who can move
things with their minds of people
who have telepathic powers on.
Our automatic reaction is to just dismiss
all of that because science says it's
impossible.
Um,
B be B because a science regards
consciousnesses as local to the brain and
doesn't see how it can exert
itself, uh, outside of that.
But maybe we should open up to those
possibilities that we're dealing with a
very different kind of culture that
used techniques that we have allowed to
lapse. And maybe we could wake
those techniques up again.
Maybe the ability of human beings to
do almost superhuman things is resident
within all of us,
but sleeping
well, it's pure speculation that they
use some sort of a telekinetic power,
but it's pure speculation,
but it's absolute that they did
something that we don't understand.
If you think about the distance
between us and the construction,
just the modern accepted construction
dates of the great pyramid.
It's more than 5,000 years ago
or close to 5,000 years ago.
It's supposed to be about 4,500
years old. Yeah, that's really old.
Incredibly incredible to think that
someone back then could do something that
would perplex us today with modern
machinery and that somehow or another,
they figured this out.
It's almost like what they had done
was leave behind something that was so
stupendous,
so monstrously impressive that it would
transcend time and that you would have
to look at it even thousands and thousands
of years later and say, hey, like this,
this defies conventional explanation.
This is not assemble.
And I've seen some of the conventional
explanations of the construction of the
pyramid, and they conveniently neglect
those chambers above the king's chamber.
They do. They conveniently neglect
a lot of those massive stones.
And it's because it's, it's one of those
things you just go, oh, I don't know.
What does this Jeremy, they're
the, they're the chairs
about the above,
the above the king's chambers and each
one of those floors is consists of a row
of 70 ton granite blocks that had been
raised 350 feet above the ground and not
only that but brought from
Aswan in the south of Egypt,
500 kilometers south of the
south of the Great Pyramid.
If there's any time in history where you
could go in a time machine and go back
and observe,
would that be the time?
I am just completely fascinated
by the ice age at the moment.
If you had one shot to go back and see
what it was like in some place, you
wouldn't go to the construction
of the Great Pyramids.
I think right now where I'd go is
12,800 years ago in the beginning of the
younger dryas just to see because I
think that's where the whole human story
changes.
I think that's where we change tracks
from one path to another path and
following those cataclysmic events of
the younger dryas between twelve thousand
eight hundred and eleven thousand six
hundred years ago, following those,
the signs of civilization that we see
emerging are not the beginnings of
civilization there a restarting of
civilization that had existed before the
cataclysm. And for that
reason, um, I would, uh,
I would like to be present
during that cataclysmic event,
if only to satisfy myself that it was
indeed a comet. You see, the, the,
the one thing,
there's no dispute about any more is
that the younger dryas was a cataclysm,
the Yukon. They can't argue
about that. The, the, the,
the megafauna that, uh, that,
that die off, the disruption of human
activity that takes place at that time,
the huge climate changes.
This was a cataclysm by any standards
where the arguments still goes on is what
caused that.
What caused the cataclysm.
I vote strongly for commit multiple
fragments of a comet hitting the North
American ice cap and
hitting Greenland as well.
But there are other researchers in the
field, like my colleague Robert Schoch,
who thinks that the sudden is more
involved. This is healthy. This is very,
very healthy that there should,
we should be approaching this problem
from many different perspectives and
trying to figure out what the fuck cause
this extraordinary event that occurs at
a pivotal moment in the human story,
the end of the Stone Age,
the beginning of the Misa
Lithic the end of the ice age,
the beginning of the
current age of the earth,
and suddenly we see these signs of
civilization appearing and in places like
Gabelli,
Tepi.
Those signs already include
highly sophisticated knowledge
and that's why I feel
we really need to investigate the Amazon.
There are,
there are three places in the world
which are really lacking in the
investigation right now.
One of them is the Amazon five and
a half million square kilometers,
very little archaeology done. Another
is the Sahara desert, the Sahara desert,
tough place to work. I can understand why
there's little archaeology done there,
but the Sahara desert was
green during the ice age.
It had a completely
different climate regime.
We should consider the possibility that
missing parts of the human story are
there. And then under the continental
shelves, because sea level rose 400 feet,
these are three domains that archeology
has largely not investigated.
And, and it is largely not
done. So they say, well,
why would we spend the
money on marine archeology?
It's much better to spend it on looking
for shipwrecks rather than looking for
signs of a lost civilization
because we archeologist, no,
there was no lost civilization. So that's
the argument for the resources there.
And, and the same, the same with the
Amazon. And the same with the, with,
with the Sahara desert places in the very
places in the world that those amongst
us who are charged with the responsibility
of interpreting the past have not
looked at, are the very prices
we should be looking at.
I have a thought once while
I was under the influence
and it was um,
a thought that one day computational
powers will reach a point where they will
be able to take into consideration all
of the objects on earth and what we know
about the history and the vividly
recreate the past through,
through computation to the point where
you could actually know who did what when
people did things and that at man,
I don't even know if this would be
physical today, certainly not be possible,
but with the exponential increase in
computational power and technology and
innovation that one day we'll reach a
point where you'll be able to watch,
you'll be able to see what happened
and they'll be able to recreate what
happened exactly. And that this
would be something that would be,
it's impossible for us to imagine that
someone would be able to do that right
now.
But that one day with technology as it
gets more and more advanced and we will
reach some sort of,
uh,
some innovation or some
sort of an invention that
will allow us to go back and
see, literally see what, what
happened, how things were done.
Tech technologies is changing.
Our whole understanding of the past
and what you're envisaging is perfectly
possible. We will, we will
come to a time if 100 years,
500 times less if, if we don't, you know,
first destroy ourselves
entirely as a civilization.
We will come to a time
where our cleverness and our
techniques will allow a much
wider opening up of the past
then his presently happened,
but it is already happening.
Um,
one of the areas of science that I go
into in America before his genetics and
DNA, uh, this is an area
of science that, uh,
was not much informing
archeology until about the 1990s.
But since the two thousands has become
very important in archeology because the
technology has been developed
where ancient DNA can be
extracted and tested and
you can actually genotype
an entire individual from
DNA that may be 15, 20,000,
20,000 years old. Um, and this, uh,
new technology of genome sequencing and,
and DNA is another factor that is raising
huge question marks over the past of
the America's.
And one of the issues I go into a in
this book is the presence in the Amazon
rain forest of a very specific,
clearly identifiable pattern of DNA,
which is only found in one other place
in the world. And that is in Australasia,
uh, in Papua New Guinea and
amongst Australian aborigines,
it's Australasian Dna.
Uh, now South America,
not only in South America,
but in the depths of the Amazon rain
forest amongst tribes who have only been
contacted in the last 20 or 30
years. Uh, and further, more,
although skeletal remains
are rare,
it has been found in ancient skeletal
remains that are close to 11,000 years old
in the Amazon.
So that tells us that this DNA signal has
been in the Amazon for at least 11,000
years. The geneticists think that it came
to the Amazon during the last ice age.
And this raises a huge mystery because
the peopling of the Americas is supposed
to have occurred from Siberia
across the Bering Straits,
down through that ice free
corridor into North America,
down through North America, into
South America, into Central America,
and finally into South America.
If that was the whole story,
then we would find this DNA signal in
North America and in Central America.
We would not find it only in the Amazon.
When I talked to some of the
leading geneticists about
this, but specifically, um,
Escott professor,
SK Willis level at the University of
Copenhagen has been the lead author in a
number of major studies of Ancient Dna.
And I asked him,
what do you make of this Australasian Dna,
uh, in, in the Amazon? And, and he said,
honestly, we don't have a proper
explanation for it at, at the moment.
But what he did say is that the
most parsimonious explanation,
he used that specific word,
the most parsimonious explanation is
that a group of people during the ice age
crossed the Pacific Ocean and settled
up and ended up in South America and
settled in the Amazon and
brought their DNA with them.
That would account
perfectly for the DNA data.
And when a scientist says the
most parsimonious explanation,
what that scientist is saying is he likes
that explanation that it's a simple,
direct, clear explanation of the DNA
mystery. But then he added, however,
it doesn't make practical
sense. And I asked him, well,
why doesn't it make practical sense?
And he said,
because the archeologists tell me that
no human population was capable of
crossing the Pacific
Ocean during the ice age.
At which point it was
natural for me to say,
do you really trust the
archeologists? And he said, well,
in science we do trust the work of other
scientists. We don't really question it.
We don't really investigate it.
That's their side of the,
their side of the
business. Um, and, and my,
my view is that that is
rather than rather than excel,
rather than taking this weird anomalous
Austra Lazy and Dna Signal, uh,
in the, in the, in the
heart of the Amazon, uh,
as something to be explained a way and
as something to be for it to be denied,
that it could, it could be connected
to a voyage across the Pacific Ocean.
Maybe it's the first compelling evidence
that voyages were taking place across
the Pacific Ocean during the ice age.
And maybe we should be opening up that
whole issue for exploration. And again,
I think I lost a lost
civilization is the best answer.
And that near the end of the ice age when,
when the younger dryas cataclysm unfolds,
it's not an overnight thing.
It's very bad. 12,000, 800
years ago, there's about 1000,
200 years of horror.
I don't think the civilization went
down in a single day and night.
I think there were survivors,
I think bits of it were left.
I think their project was
to restart civilization.
And I suggest very strongly that where
they tried to mount that project was
amongst the hunter gatherers who coexisted
in the world with them at that time.
We ourselves are an advanced civilization,
at least that's what we call ourselves.
And we coexist in the world
with hunter gatherers. Uh,
it's not an odd idea that
an advanced civilization,
a hunter gather as should coexist and
there is separation between us and the
Amazonian hunter gathers.
There are tribes in the Amazon
that are uncontacted and that we,
that we don't know even
exist if catastrophe on the
level of the younger dryas
were to occur today.
I don't think that our
civilization would make it through.
We are the spoiled children of the earth.
We are just used to having
everything laid on. You know,
the supermarket shelves are groaning with,
with food.
We can get food delivered to our homes.
We have roofs over our head.
We have shelters, we have coding.
Everything is taken for granted.
I guess you an exception.
But very few people in modern
western culture know how to survive.
They don't have survival skills.
They don't know how to hunt.
They don't know how to gather.
They don't know how to grow crops because
they've handed that responsibility
over to others.
We live in a society
that's highly segmented and
specialized in different people
specialize in different things,
but nobody has the vast general survival
skill that a hunter gatherer has.
So in a global cataclysm,
actually at first counterintuitively,
the people who would survive it would
be the hunter gatherers and an advanced
civilization would be smart if they were
survivors to seek refuge amongst hunter
gatherers, uh, to, to make that the
place where they might try to start,
restart their civilization.
And that's why I think that this Austria
Lazy and DNA signal in the Amazon may
be part of the evidence for a sort of
outreach effort that was being made by a
lost civilization.
Seeing the disaster coming down on it
and realizing that something needed to be
done well,
it's fascinating to me
that the geneticists would
rely on the archeologists
being that the geneticists
have the actual DNA,
they can examine where the archeologists
are piecing things together.
Absolutely tiny bits of information
over the entire landscape.
And then you consider how much information
they don't have access to that's in
the ground. Exactly. I,
I strongly resist the idea
that archeology is a science.
I don't think it should
be described as a science.
What do you think it should be described?
It's more like a kind of philosophy.
It's a, it's, it's a, it's an
attempt to interpret the past, uh,
based on rather flimsy
and limited evidence.
And what you find in that interpretation
is that the preconceptions of the
individuals involved are being
imposed upon the evidence,
which then turns out to
support their preconceptions.
And that's not a scientific
way of doing things.
A scientific way of
doing things is testing,
testing hypotheses and false seeking
to falsify them and seeing if, if they,
if they work out.
So the problem is drawing
these conclusions and then
being too rigid with these
conclusions on the further evidence.
That's, that's my view that, that,
that archeology has been,
has been much too rigid and,
and the, and that there's a,
there's a climate of fear in archeology.
I don't mean to pick particularly
on archeologists here,
I think this is generally true
across other disciplines as well.
Um, these days academics are driven by
the need to publish research papers.
That's what they build their careers on.
If they can get a paper on their bit
of research published in nature of the
proceedings of the National
Academy of Sciences, et Cetera,
that's good for their careers.
But then you confront the gatekeepers
in those publications who regard any
archeological idea that is not part of
the mainstream accepted consensus with
great suspicion and are most
most reluctant, uh, to, to,
you know, to publish, to
publish that information. Now,
what is the mainstream, what, when,
when archeologists talk about
seafaring humans, when, what,
what did they date that too?
Well, there's the great,
the great seafaring adventure that is
accepted by archeology is called the
Polynesian expansion.
And it's a remarkable story.
And that occurs roughly
3000 to 3,500 years ago.
And those Polynesians were amazing
ocean navigators. They could,
they could cross distances of thousands
of kilometers with pinpoint accuracy.
I mean,
it's not an accident that the Polynesians
found Easter island fighting Easter
island is a really challenging project.
Easter island is 2000 miles
from the coast of South America.
It's 2000 miles from the nearest
other island, which is Tahiti.
It's just a little speck
in the middle of the ocean.
But the Polynesians found it and settled
there and appear to have brought a
reproductively viable population there
and appear to have made voyages back and
forth.
But that was 3000 to 3,500 years ago.
That was not 12,800 years
ago. Uh, and this is,
this is where archeology is adamant
position that ocean voyaging was begun by
the Polynesians and that there
was no major ocean voyages before.
That I think needs to be strongly
questioned and it needs to be strongly
questioned in the light of this DNA
evidence from the Amazon rather than
rejecting the evidence and attempt should
be made to consider what that might
mean. Well, it's interesting because we
know that the Egyptians had boats. Yeah.
And so what I mean,
if there were boats 4,500 years ago,
why do we think that they didn't
try them out in the ocean?
That doesn't make any sense. Especially
if there existed a thousand years prior,
which is also possible.
Archeologist wouldn't argue
that the Egyptians had boats,
but, but that is, that is still within
the framework of accepted history. It's,
it's the notion of a,
of a global navigating culture in the
ice age that archeologists can't swallow.
It's a subject that I've kept on coming
up against over a number of years.
I think the best evidence
for it is ancient maps, uh,
which show the world as it
looked during the last ice age.
I've first explored this in fingerprints
of the gods and I've touched on the
mystery again and I haven't had
an appendix on the subject in, in,
in this book because I think
these are very important.
We're talking about maps that were drawn
roughly between the 13 hundreds and the
17 hundreds. Uh, in other words,
in relatively recent history,
however,
these maps were largely based
on much older source maps,
which they copied.
And we can say that for sure because
one of the famous maps is the period
[inaudible] map which was created by a
Turkish admiral called Perry Reece in the
year 1513. Uh, actually only a
corner of his map has survived.
It was originally a world map.
We now just have a bit that shows the
east coast of South America and North
America and the west coast of Africa.
Peary Reece writes in that map that it
is in his own handwriting that he based
it on more than 100 older source maps,
some of which had come from the
library of Alexandria. In other words,
that maps had been when the library of
Alexandria had been destroyed in the
fourth century idea whenever it was,
some of its contents had been rescued
and brought to Constantinople,
which became the Turkish capitol and Peary
Reese had access to those maps and he
incorporated information from those maps
on his maps as well as incorporating
more recent navigational information.
And this is one of a whole category of
maps which are extremely hard to explain.
All of them based on older source maps.
Now lost all of them.
Incorporating extremely precise
relative longitudes and latitudes.
Latitude is not that difficult
to technological feat,
but longitude is a difficult
technological feat.
Longitude involves a chronometer.
It involves knowing the
time at the place you began,
your voyage and the local
and local noon as well.
And calculating the
difference between them.
You need a chronometer that we'll keep
accurate time at sea with the Mo motions
of a ship. And it's just a plain fact that
our civilization did not invent such a
chronometer until the late 18th century.
Before that we didn't know what
longitude where we were at.
And ships were constantly
sailing unexpectedly into
coastlines that they thought
were hundreds of miles further away.
So the discovery of the technique to do
longer chewed was a major civilizational
advance.
Its presence in maps based on much
older source maps that actually show the
world as it looks during the last ice age
suggests that somebody during the last
ice age was mapping the world and had
mastered the technique of calculating a
longer shoot. Classic
example of these maps. Um,
and I make a point of this is what's
called the Pinkerton world map,
which was drawn in the year 18,
18 and it was based on the latest
navigational information at that time.
I reproduce that map in
the, in, in the book.
What's missing from the map
entirely missing is Antarctica.
There's just a hole at the bottom
of the world. There's nothing there.
And the reason, there's a reason,
there's nothing, there's another,
there's another Pinkerton map that uh,
that shows that the,
the reason that you need to find one
that's centered on Antarctica, the reason,
the reason that Antarctica is not
there is that our civilization hadn't
discovered Antarctica in 1818 so they
couldn't authentically put it on a map in
1818.
Actually we discovered it in 18,
19 and that's when it starts
appearing on modern maps.
The problem is that Antarctica repeat
appears repeatedly on these much older
maps and it appears in the right place,
uh, and a bit bigger than it is today,
but very much as it looked
during the last ice age.
So what all of this suggests to me is
that the world was mapped and explored by
a global seafaring culture with the
level of technology that was at least
equivalent to ours at the end of the
18th century. Uh, during the ice age.
Wasn't there also a map of Greenland
that showed it underneath the ice? Yes,
there are. And, and, and, and, uh,
another intriguing thing I met,
I mentioned the Peary Reece map just now
shown on the Perry Reece map lying off
the east coast of North America is a
large island with a row of megaliths,
like a road of megaliths
running up the middle of it. Um,
that island is in the exact place
of the Grand Bahama banks. Uh, and,
and uh, just one. Yeah, it is. Um,
but can I point it out
to you because I'm sure
that's right. Okay. That one. Okay, that's
great that you can bring this up Jeremy.
So this island is sitting there off
the southeast coast of North America.
I think we have these to
dry things back then too.
And what you see running down the middle
of it is this road like feature of our
main list.
I see right there.
Now the thing is,
it was a long period of my life when I,
I did a lot of scuba diving and I was
looking at an underwater structures and
one of the sites I dived
on was the Bimini road,
which is in the Grand Bahama banks.
And the remedy road is exactly
where the island is and the that.
Here's the issue. I don't care whether
the Bimini road is natural or manmade.
For me, the mystery is that it
is shown above water on that map.
And the last time it was above water was
thousands and thousands of years ago.
So for me,
this is all evidence that we shouldn't
dismiss the possibility that our
ancestors had achieved a
level of technology where
they could explore in that
the world's oceans.
We shouldn't dismiss that.
We don't know what those stones are,
how they were created, but bully.
Do they look artifacts you on a
Goonie and Japan we're looking at now,
but the back to that image to me did the
last image that we were just looking at
it. Look at that. That looks so man man.
And you can see that as rather like the,
the, the pattern that's showing on
the, on the island in the, in the map.
How deep is that today? Oh, it's not
very deep. It's about 20 feet. There's,
but we think that that was
above water at some point.
This trip was definitely above water
during the last ice age when it,
when finally went underwater.
May have been as late as
eight or 9,000 years ago.
Is there anything else compelling that's
in the immediate area that seems to
indicate that there was some sort
of a manmade structure? Well,
nobody's looked for it.
Uh,
and the whole effort of archeology has
been to dismiss the significance of the
BIM and a row. How would they dismiss
that? Well, they say it's just,
to me they say it's totally natural.
Comma is go,
go back to that image again. This,
but, but well this is the og.
You go back to that image
that we just saw. Yeah, sure.
Somebody who spent a lot of
time diving on the Bimini road.
I can tell you I absolutely
do not think it's natural.
I think it's a manmade structure,
but the argument is that it's a kind of
beach rock that forms in these blocky
for me is that a speech rock
does form in Bocky permission.
But here I believe that the beach rock
has been used as a construction material.
But I repeat,
the key issue is not whether the
Bimini road is manmade or not.
The key issue is that it
features on the map above water.
And that is a dating project that tells
us that somebody was mapping that bit of
the world when it was above water.
And that takes us back a very long,
a long way into the past. The one
that you just pulled up, you know,
look at that one. That's a stunning
place. It's this amazing site.
It's just like the odds of that being
in that order with those uniformly sized
rocks for how long has that Oh,
hundreds of feet. It's, it's a huge,
it's actually shaped like the letter j.
It's a giant underwater structure.
It's really,
really an enormous thing and very,
very beautiful dive on and there's lots
of very gentle sweet nurse sharks down
there that you can play with it.
So that looks much more like random.
That's more random and bits of it,
bits of it do look more random bits of
it look highly constructed. I would not,
I would not seek to to claim that the
Bimini road is absolutely manmade.
My claim about the Bimini road is,
it's really fucking weird that
it appears on a map above water,
a map that was drawn in 1513
based on older source map.
Now when they found that ancient Greek uh,
computer thing and what, what does that
call Denton Kai Theora mechanism? Yes.
Again,
that testifies to a lost navigational
skill that we have not taken account of
incredibly complex and it took a long
time for them to figure out what that even
is. What do they think that
is now? Um, it, it tracks
the movements of the planets.
It's a, it's a navigational
device. It's a, it, it, it,
it's a geared cogged system that allows
you to track the passage of time and
figure out where you are.
It's,
it's some kind of navigational devices
not fully understood. And how old is that?
I think that goes back to Greek times.
I'm guessing here because the Greek
times are not of great interest to me,
but I'm thinking around about 500 BC.
So at least 2000 years old.
2000 plus.
And we know that there had to be
more than one of these things. Yes.
It, you can't, you can't have
something like that without,
without a vast effort behind it.
Human beings,
we're working on creating this geared
and cogged machinery, uh, that,
that reflected the patterns that are
recreated. That's a recreation. Wow.
Do you keep I one of those,
it looks like you buy that dude fine.
Bookmark that.
We need one right there,
right next to the plastic cells.
And so such a thing is a is a cultural
artifact which doesn't just appear out of
nowhere. It hasn't, it has to have a
context. It has to have a background.
And again,
my suggestion would be
perhaps a secret technology.
It's very odd that very few of these
have been found and it may be that ship
owners and navigators in Greek times,
we're extremely careful about who they
shared this technology where of course it
made, they may, it may have been as top
secret as you know, nuclear power is in,
in, in our world today. Oh,
that makes sense. But the
fact is that then we have to,
we, it exists. It's real,
it's there and then we must
consider what's behind it. What,
what led to that?
Is that just the latest manifestation
of something that that goes much more
deeply back into human, human
culture? And I think that is, I think,
I suppose my main, my main
messages that we have, uh,
so far untold backstory that
we're concentrating entirely
on the front story and
the backstory is missing,
very largely missing from the picture.
And what I've tried to do is to
fill in bits of the backstory.
Do you have anything in this book
about the Omex? No, not really. Um, I,
I mentioned, I mentioned them briefly.
Uh, I explored the old Mac mystery,
uh, in considerable depth can explain that
to people maybe in the fingerprints of
the gods.
A yes.
So it's considered to be the earliest
high culture of Central America.
Everybody's heard about the Aztecs,
everybody's heard about the Maya.
But before the Aztecs and before the Maya,
there were a culture who are
referred to as the old Max.
Again,
we don't know what they called themselves.
That's what the Aztecs called them.
They called them the old Mexican.
It means the rubber people because they
see a rubber producing area of, uh,
of Mexico.
They worked in a giant
megalithic constructions
that what they're most famous
for is these huge carved human heads,
which can be on a scale of up
to 20 to 25 tons in weight,
uh, and, and which have curious features
which have been interpreted variously as
Polynesian African don't look like
classic native American features.
But one of the things,
one of the things I've realized is that
there is no classic native American
feature that that native
Americans are a very,
have a very complex genetic story with
very many different elements brought into
it and we shouldn't be necessarily
surprised by the supposedly non native
American look. These are my kids. They do.
We think those helmets where they're
wearing nobody knows because no physical
example of such a helmet
has ever been found.
Just like no physical example of an
Egyptian Pharaohs hell a crown has it has
ever been found. All we see is the stone.
The stone reproductions of them do.
They're universally wear these
helmets and they say all day.
They pretty much all wear these helmets
in, in, in, in the ALMAC stonework.
There's another fascinating figure from
La Venta when one of the Omex sites,
which is the earliest ever image
of a plumed or feathered serpent.
The feathered serpent is a famous icon
in Central America, quite sal collateral,
who's the god of peace,
the bringer of civilization
who is associated, for example,
with the famous pyramid of,
of Cookwell con,
which is just another name for quite
awhile, Catholic church, Anita,
where on the spring equinox,
a shadow effect creates the image of a
serpent coiling down the stairway and
joining with the carved head
of the serpent or the bears,
the image from La Venta.
That's the earliest image of a
plumed serpent in the Americas.
And sitting in the middle of it,
and I made a big deal out of this cause
I think it is a big deal in magicians of
the gods sitting in the middle of it
is this human figure who's holding this
strange bag in his hand.
And it's just a fact that those identical
bags are found in ancient sooner in
the hands of individuals who were
considered to be civilization bringers.
And they also show up on pillar
43 at Gabelli Beckley Tepi,
I call the man bags. Uh, and in
that case it got back to the Tempe.
We know they're at least 11,600 years old.
So I wonder if we are looking at a
sort of badge of office of a group of
civilizes who traveled around the world
trying to bring back to life a lost
civilization and pass down.
I deploy a concept in this book that
I actually got from Richard Dawkins.
Richard Richard Dawkins is the author
of the book called the selfish gene.
And he's not one of my
favorite people because he's a,
he's a materialist reductionist and
he doesn't believe in spirit or,
or any mystery in life that were just
accidents of chemistry and biology.
We also has no psychedelic experience.
And he said no,
I did challenge him at a public event to,
to go to go have a dozen sessions of
Iowasca and its still gas at once or just
once would be enough. But he has
an excellent out because, uh,
and sadly he's had a,
he's had a stroke so he has a good
excuse for not for not doing that,
but he's a clever man.
And one of his concepts
that he's introduced into
human culture is the concept
of the meme. We're off, I
think familiar with that word.
Genes are a physical
reproductive mechanisms.
They reproduce themselves down
the generations they replicate,
they multiply their passed on
from one individual to another.
Memes are cultural objects,
cultural ideas that are passed on and
replicate and reproduce themselves and
what I see right across the Americas and
right across the old world as well is a
set of memes that involve the sky,
that involve the ground,
that involved geometry,
that involve notions of life after death,
and I think the only way to explain these
is that they have been inherited from
an earlier culture that was in some way
connected with the ancestors of all of
these, all of these cultures. I think
that's what we are looking in the Amazon.
We're looking at a meme which
was deliberately created.
Once you mobilize the population to start
creating huge geometrical structures,
you are also facilitating many other
possibilities that an organized population
allows. I think that's what
happened at got Beckley Tepi.
I think that's why they
created the Megalithic site
there to mobilize the local
population of hunter gatherers,
to give them a project to do,
to engage them and in the process of
engaging them to teach them the skills of
agriculture which were, which, which
are fundamental to any concept of,
of civilization.
And it's weird the way agriculture
just suddenly appears in in Quebec,
the tappy and there's huge agricultural
mysteries in the Amazon as well.
Um, may I share a couple
of leaves messages with you
before you do that though?
Can you pull up that image from Gabelli?
Tapi of pillar was the pillar
4,343 in enclosure day.
I would like to see that that
guy holding that bag. That is,
the bags are in a row along
the top of the pillow. Um,
it's pillar 43 in, in an enclosure d
at go back to the Tempe. Is there a,
an image of that online? It's
available. Okay, here we go. Yeah,
there's the bags in a row and a row
along the top as the same sort of square
shaped bag with a curved handle that
you find on the earliest image of the
pillar of the feathered serpent. And that
you find, no, you have to go above that,
Jamie. Um, just a little bit higher
up the pillar. That was Max, right,
right, right at the top there. It's
odd that this symbol crops up in,
in many different cultures and tends
to be associated with some kind of
interpretation of those. There's no
mainstream interpretation of those bags.
That's my interpretation of those bags,
uh, which I, which I freely confess.
That's how,
that's how I read them.
I'm intrigued by the anomaly that the
similar bag and turns up in the hands of
the quite so collateral figure and turns
up in Mesopotamia repeatedly, um, in,
in the hands of the individuals who
are called the App Kalu the, the,
the magicians of the gods,
the beginning bringers of civilization,
the plume serpent [inaudible] Quadel
was, it's an Aztec card, right.
And quest quest of collateral is
an Aztec is an Aztec God. But,
but the Aztecs acquired
him from earlier cultures.
The very fact that an image of the plumed
serpent is given such priority in all
met culture tells us that that system of
ideas was present during all Mac Times,
which takes us back at least to 1500 BC
probably quite a bit earlier than that.
Where's the Aztecs are 1,580.
So there's 3000 years between
the Aztecs and the Olmecs.
And that same system of ideas is
running through all of those cultures.
And the Mayans had a name
for it as well. Cool. Cool.
Con and what do you think
that plumed serpent was?
I think he's the,
it's very clear from,
from the accounts that have survived that
what he's associated with a two things
in PR in particular. One of
them, he's a god of peace.
He's not a a war God. Uh, and the,
and the other thing that he's
primarily about is giving the gifts of
civilization.
This is what you,
human beings need to know in order
to move on to the next level.
Uh, that is, that is the function
and the role of quite our collateral.
And it's there are very similar,
we could refer to them as civilizing
heroes who are found in other cultures and
other locations, or Cyrus in
Egypt plays that role, uh,
as a bringer of civilization.
There's hardly a culture in the ancient
world that doesn't remember a time far
back in remote prehistory when some
kind of supernatural or advanced human
beings. And I prefer the latter. That's
some kind of advanced human beings.
We're involved in a project
to disseminate a civilization.
I mentioned the Chicano in the Amazon who,
who are big drinkers
of, of, of Iowasca. Uh,
the Takano have a fascinating origin myth.
Uh,
they say that they're an origin myth
state specifically that their ancestors
were brought to the Amazon.
They were brought to the Amazon by a
group of supernaturals who included the
daughter of the sun and an individual
called the helmsmen who steered the
serpent canoe in which this settlement
mission in the Amazon was, was performed.
And what these so called
supernatural dead was,
they brought the ancestors of Decano to
the Amazon and they showed them the best
places to settle the
best places where they,
where they might find hunting the best
places where they might create a village
of the best places for agriculture.
And then they left,
but they left them behind one gift
and that gift was Iowasca. Wow.
That's the story of the
origin myth of the Takano.
And it sounds to me rather like the other
side of the story of that DNA signal
in the Amazon that a group of people
were deliberately settled, uh,
in the Amazon by human beings who they
chose to regard as a supernatural.
That's what makes sense of it to me.
Um,
when I interrupted you to talk about
what's, or what were you about to say?
I can't remember. I'm in
California. I've been smoking dope.
We were talking about different things
in the Amazon. Should we rewind?
We said the serpent. God, you were
talking about before quite so.
Quantile before that. Um, I have
another question. The omex did you,
you were talking about the
genetics of these, um, uh,
people that live in native
Americans that they vary widely,
but the old mex seemed to
have very similar features,
the thick lips and noses.
Why do we think that is?
Well, this is part of, uh,
a curious mystery that is not
unconnected to the genetic mystery.
Uh,
it's been known by archeologists for
quite a long time that there are anomalous
skulls, uh, in parts of Brazil,
which appear to show a very strongly
Polynesian or African features,
very much like the features that we
see on the, on the all make heads.
And a number of archeologists who got
into trouble with their colleagues for
this have used that to argue many
years ago, 30, 40 years ago, that,
that the settlement story of the Americas
is much more complicated than we've,
you know, then we, than we've
realized and, and what the,
what the DNA is doing is it's telling
us that there was something really weird
happened, happened with settlement. They,
you see, what happened with those, um,
African or Polynesian looking skulls
was that they were tested for DNA.
Uh, when DNA technology was
not as advanced as it is today.
And what that DNA showed was that they
were more closely related to modern
native Americans than they are
to any other people in the world.
So the notion that there was some
connection with Polynesia or Africa was
dismissed,
but now that we have very firm evidence
of an Austrian lazy and genetic signal
or Australian aborigines,
Papua New Guinea Melanesians
with those kinds of features,
now that we have the genetic evidence
that is found in the amps and we have to
go back to that old evidence
and reconsider it. Wow. Yeah,
I would love to find out what that is.
They've always fascinated me.
The OMEX, it's always been
such a strange image. The,
the large heads with the helmets on them.
And how did they universally
look like that? I mean all the,
all of the features are very,
very similar.
They're very similar with the
helmets and almost always,
I won't claim that every single
Omac head has a helmet on it.
Cause I think I've seen one that didn't,
there's quite a while ago since
I explored the Almac area.
But what's fascinating
about them is they are,
they are supposedly the first high
civilization of Central America that they
create structures on a massive scale that
you can see connections between them.
And the later,
the later Maya,
that whole mystery of the Mayan calendar
was clearly inherited from the all Max.
It wasn't something that Maya made up.
The all max use that same symbolism.
So the Mayan calendar is
actually an Almanac calendar.
And if we then consider the possibility
that the all macs may just be the latest,
the earliest surviving
manifestation of that calendar,
it could go back much further than that.
Do you plan on having any debates
with people that oppose these ideas?
Um, well it was interesting
on your very show, Joe too,
to have the debate that
involved Michael Shermer,
who's the editor of the
skeptic magazine and um,
some colleague of his who came in on
line who I got a bit annoyed with,
um, and um, myself and, uh,
my great friend and colleague,
the genius Randall Carlson, uh, and,
and I felt that that was
a very useful debate.
Um, I felt that it's poss possibly
the first time that those of us on the
alternative side of the argument about
history where we're given an opportunity
really to put our evidence forward and,
and to confront so-called
skeptics while it's so cold.
That's what he calls himself,
Michael Shermer with this evidence.
And obviously I'm biased,
but I,
I don't feel that he fielded
the situation particularly well.
I don't think mainstream mark LG
came out of that looking really good.
I think it came out of that looking
rather ignorant and uninformed.
Uh, and, and a man like Michael
Shermer, who is a professional skeptic,
uh, cannot begin to match the knowledge
of a man like Randall Carlson who has
devoted his whole life to walking the
walk of the geology of the end of the ice
age in, in, in North America. And
that showed on, on, on that debate.
So I think the debate was worth doing a,
I think it showed that the alternative
side isn't just wishy washy stuff out
there on the fringes of things,
that there are those of us working in
this field who are using really solid
information.
And who are who our project is to rewrite
history and we're not going to do that
with slight information.
It has to be solid information.
I think we had the opportunity
on your show to say that,
that that solid information is there.
I'm not claiming it was a complete
victory for the alternative side.
Michael Shermer is a smart guy and he
put forward some good arguments to,
and there were constructive
aspects of that debate, which I,
which I appreciate it.
I'd like to see much more engagement
and much more positive approach.
I wished the skeptics
welcome to their skepticism,
but I wish they'd be less hateful,
less less full of derision, less,
less despising,
or they're so defensive with their ideas
and and so and so defensive with their
ideas when the possibility is there for,
for a constructive debate, you know? Well,
what's interesting to me is that as this
evidence piles up and it seems to be
continuing to pile up as more like the,
the impact sites and more of this ancient
civilization material gets unearthed,
it's almost insurmountable.
Yeah. It's almost, and this is
how this is how paradigm shift,
I mean everybody is familiar with the
concept of a paradigm shift and there's a
book called the structure of
scientific revolutions by Thomas Kuhn,
which outlines what a paradigm shift is,
where an established model in some
discipline of science that has been in
control of people's thinking for a very
long time suddenly falls apart and it
doesn't fall apart.
Suddenly what happens is that there's
an accumulation of evidence which that
model cannot explain.
That paradigm cannot explain it.
It seemed like a great
paradigm at one point,
but then it doesn't explain this
and then it doesn't explain like,
like the paradigm that says
that Megalithic architecture
is only 6,000 years old
and that the first megalithic architecture
was in Multa that can't explain the
massive Megalithic site of Quebec, Lee
Tempe and Turkey 5,500 years before that.
It's evidence like that the slow
accumulation of evidence that the existing
system cannot explain
that at eventual point,
no matter how strongly the advocates
of the existing system hold on to it,
no matter how determined
they are in their defense,
no matter what dirty tricks they may
choose to deploy to undermine their
opponents,
sooner or later,
the evidence overwhelms them and the
paradigm goes down and you have a new way
of thinking and that that is the story of,
of science.
And it is a story that I think,
I think we're at a tipping point in our
understanding of the past of the human
species.
I am not saying that I am 100% right.
I believe that what I'm doing that's
worthwhile is I'm asking questions about
the past that haven't been asked enough.
I'm putting archeologist on the spot and,
and demanding that they
explain themselves. I don't,
I don't claim that I'm right.
I'm offering an alternative theory.
And my objective is to get
people to think for themselves,
to think about this stuff and not to
accept, uh, the voice of authority as the,
as the sole, uh, medium of truth.
That's, that's what I've tried to do.
Have you had any,
uh,
archeologist review any of this
work and change their opinions? No.
No I haven't. But what I, what
I have found, uh, and I've,
I've found it interestingly during the
research trips for America before a,
is a younger generation of
archeologists who are in the field. Um,
and they are quite different from the
older generation of archeologists who are
running the whole scene
25 years ago or now.
We have a very different
younger generation and younger
generation that has been
exposed to open minded thinking, um,
that has been exposed to the Internet.
That itself as part of the general
pattern of the younger generation is
suspicious of authority. I'm meeting
young archeologist on sites. For example,
I met a couple of really
amazing young minds, uh,
on a site called Blackwater
draw, uh, in, um, uh,
Arizona and New Mexico where,
where the one of the first Clovis sites,
the young archeologist I met there
were incredibly open minded and,
and really willing to
consider extraordinary
possibilities about the past and
privately admitted to me that
they'd read my books. Well,
that's where I get the hope.
I get the hope in this young generation
that is growing up with the Internet
that does understand that there's a lot
more out there than just what they're
being taught in schools. Yes. Yeah.
Isn't this, is this, this is where the,
where the hope lies and it lies in, in
every area. And it's why one of the,
one of the intriguing things that has
happened with me and your show is an
important part of this is that when
I go around giving public events,
doing a public presentation of my work,
the demography of the audiences
is extremely interesting.
And this is true whether I'm
giving the talk in Britain,
whether I'm giving it in Canada,
whether I'm giving it in America.
Part of the audience are older people
who read me in the 1990s who got onto my
work with fingerprints of the Gods in
1995 and they've stuck with me and they've
carried on reading my work.
But another part of the audience,
and a very big part of the
audience consists to a large
extent of young people,
most of whom are men,
but there are women amongst them as well.
And what those mainly young men come up
to me and say at the end of the event is
we first encountered your work on Joe
Rogan's show and it completely opened our
minds. It changed it. I've had so many
young men say, this has changed my life.
And then I asked myself,
well,
why should a different take on
the past change people's lives?
Why should people feel that their lives
have been changed by a different take on
the past, which I add they would not know
about unless you had the good grace to,
to bring me on the, on, on your show.
This, these ideas would not be known,
but they are known because of the
amazing outreach of your show.
And the answer to that question,
why does it,
why does it change a person's life is
that once we realize that we have been
misinformed about our past,
that everything that we've built,
our idea of who we are upon and of where
we're going as a culture may be founded
on false hoods and perhaps
even deliberate lies.
Once that is realized,
then all the questions about the nature
of the society we live in become open.
Uh, and, and people,
young people are feeling the need
to take an independent path, not to,
not to follow the path that has
been set down for them, uh, by,
by previous generations. And in some
way, and I'm very gratified to hear this,
the fact that I am an elder
now, I'm 69 next, next birthday.
The fact that I look great. Thank
you. The fact that I as an elder, um,
have consistently pursued
an independent past part,
have been willing to put up with the
shit that's been thrown at me over the
years, but have stuck to my guns and have
continued to add new information to the
dossier of information that I put forward.
That is,
and I'm encouraged to see this, that's
founders inspiring by younger people.
And what,
what better gift could an old guy hope
to leave to the world than a younger
generation who feel inspired by that
person's work to change the world? Well,
I'm very,
very thankful that I could introduce
people to you because your first book that
I read of you, fingerprints of the Gods
changed my view of the world. I mean,
I remember putting that book down
after I was finished and going, wow,
if he's right and like this whole
thing is a mess. Yeah. A complete mess.
Big because our idea of who we are is
very much founded in our idea of who we
were. And, and one of the,
I think one of the mistakes that's
made in our civilization is that, uh,
we are very conceited with very big
headed and we tend to review the v view,
the whole story of history as though it's
a project that leads to us that we're
what it's all about. And I
think what is, um, what is,
uh, how can I put it undermining
of the existing system,
about a new take on the past is the,
is is the notion we're not
what it's all about at all. Uh,
that there may have been an earlier
civilization that reached a high level of
advancement, perhaps different
from ours, but nevertheless,
an advanced civilization,
which was just taken out of the story
completely by a global cataclysm.
Uh, then we suddenly, we suddenly realized
that in a way we're here accidentally,
that it's not been a process
that's been all about us. Uh,
and that if we'd been misinformed
about how we got here,
then we need to get the true information
about, about what's going on. So,
so these are, um, in a way, profoundly
revolutionary ideas. They do,
they do lead people on a path of inquiry
that leads to questioning of everything
and our fears that you were
just discussing earlier
about how soft we are in
comparison to past civilizations in terms
of our ability to live off the land.
That's one aspect that bothers me.
But one of the big ones that bothers me
is the fact that everything is digital.
All of our information is stored on hard
drives. You Bet. And if that goes down,
there's not much left. You have
paper books and, and you know,
a few thousands of years,
imagine what will be left. Yeah,
we would lose all of our advancement.
Well, I can, I can speak to this
at a, at a, at a personal level.
There was a time when I was
an excellent map reader.
I could navigate anywhere
with, with maps, you know,
my wife Santha and I did huge journeys
in Mexico back in the early 1990s in
really cheap hire cars with maps.
And we found our way everywhere without
any problem today I can hardly use a
map. The skill of using a map has
lapsed within me. Why? Because of GPS,
GPS technology has come along and it's,
and it,
it always tells me where I
am and being a bit lazy, uh,
I just accept that,
that technology,
but then I had caused to us myself
this just the other day. Supposing gps,
supposing all the satellites go down
and there's no gps is the whole,
the whole industrialized human race
is going to suddenly be lost. Uh,
all those Uber drivers who don't know
their way from a to B and who rely
entirely on their gps is they weren't,
no, they won't know where they're going.
And it's, and it's true with digital
data. The digital digital data,
unlike unlike print data
is I'm very fragile, uh,
and requires programs in order to
access and interpret it that a much more
complicated than simply cracking
the code of a, a lost language
mean the programs vary between
different phone platform. Exactly.
They very computer platforms. It's
just, it's so fragile and it's so,
I mean,
I don't know if there's any precautions
that have been taking place to preserve
this information in case of like what
Robert Schoch described coronal mass
ejection or something,
then click down all the satellites.
Yeah. No, I don't think,
I don't think preparation has been
made and I don't, and I don't.
And it's very clear that that preparation
is not being made for the risk of
another cosmic impact. Uh, and again,
a point that I'd like to make
about this is that we are at,
we are in a sense in a place where
history can repeat itself, uh,
that there are certain cycles at work.
Uh,
the work on the comet impact 12,000,
800 years ago.
How has very clearly and specifically
identified the Deborah trail of that
comment.
And that Deborah trail is the Taurid
meteor stream and it's called the Taurid
meteor stream because it
appears to emanate from the
region of the sky in which
the constellation of tourists sets. It
doesn't, it's within our solar system.
It's an optical illusion.
The Taurid meteor stream is
a giant complex of debris.
Uh,
it is 30 million kilometers wide.
What you had was an original comment
that might've been a hundred to 200
kilometers in diameter,
a small moon,
which fragmented and broken up
into multiple, multiple parts.
And those parts began to spread out along
the whole orbit of the Taurid meteor
stream and to widen the
whole thing widened.
So it's like a giant tube of debris and
the evidence and the argument is that
12,000,
800 years ago,
several large bits of that debris fell
out of the Taurid meteor stream and
impacted with the earth.
The problem is that the Taurid meteor
stream still exists and our planets still
passes through it twice a year.
Uh,
and those passages take place
in June and in November.
And each passage takes 12 and a half
days and the same group of scientists who
are, who are looking at the evidence for
the impacts 12,800 years ago are deeply
concerned that we may face future
impacts from the tour with meteor stream.
That there are still large objects up
there. This is not theory, this is a fact.
There's a comment up there,
uh, called [inaudible],
which is part of the Taurid meteor stream.
It's a large fragment of the original
giant comic comic Danky has a diameter of,
I don't know, five or five
or six kilometers. There's,
there's 19 recognized huge objects within
the Taurid meteor stream calculations
indicate that there may be as much as
200 asteroids within the Taurid meteor
stream of a diameter
of a kilometer or more,
which would have
catastrophic effect if they,
if they hit the earth and responsible
astronomers regard the Taurid meteor
stream as the greatest collision hazard
facing mankind at the present time.
And it's not something that we need to
fall into despair about because it's
perfectly within the level of our
technology to do something about it.
What could they do? Well,
to give you an example,
a commercial interests are looking right
now and the technology is there to mine
asteroids.
We can go to asteroids if the,
if the commercial interest is high enough,
we can go to them, we can mine them,
we can extract minerals,
we can bring them back to the earth.
The same technology would allow you
to move asteroids or comet fragments.
You don't want to blow
them up with a nuke.
That would be a really bad idea
that would, that would, uh,
turn the one large object
into multiple smaller objects,
which could cause equally
massive devastation and,
and would be very difficult to predict
where that devastation was going to fall.
What you want to do is to nudge them
and move them out of the dangerous orbit
into, into a less
dangerous Orbitz. And, and,
and the evidence is in the next 30 years,
we are going to be passing through
dangerous filaments of the toward meteor
stream.
And if we were smart,
we would be devoting some resources
to protecting our cosmic environment.
Just as we, there are many issues
that we need to devote resources to.
Unfortunately,
the one that's most attractive to our
politicians at the moment is warfare. Uh,
we devote limitless resources to
technologies of mass destruction.
There.
There really is no end to the amount
that we are prepared to spend on that in
terms of our so called security.
We feel somehow we're making ourselves
more secure by having these incredible
weapons and spending
trillions of dollars on them.
But the cosmos doesn't give
a fuck about any of that.
The Cosmos is out there with these,
with these giant, giant objects, uh,
which have a far greater explosive power
than all the nuclear weapons are stored
on earth at the, at the present
time, the comet shoemaker, Levy nine,
which hit Jupiter in 1994 had a total
calculated explosive power of 300
gigatons.
If you took the entire nuclear arsenal
of the world today and blew it all up at
once,
it would yield 6.4 gigatons.
So these objects are producing
catastrophic results on a scale that far,
far beyond anything that we ourselves
could do with nuclear weapons. It's time.
We spent a bit less time and money on
weapons of mass destruction and a bit more
on looking after this beautiful
garden that we call the earth.
And that is our home and it will be the
home of our children and our children's
children. I'm a grandfather now.
I feel passionately about this.
We need to look after this planet.
It's our responsibility as a human species
to do so. And one of the challenges,
it's not the only challenge. There
are many, many other challenges.
One of the challenges is to pay attention
to our cosmic environment and to
realize that the cosmos can intervene
cataclysmically in the human story.
And that the Taurid meteor stream in
particular may have been a hidden hand in
human history that there may have been
other impacts in the last 13,000 years
that affect have affected and changed
the course of humanity on this earth.
And the ancients were very good at
paying attention to the sky. Uh,
we ourselves have amazing
tech to study the sky,
but for some reason we're ignoring
this problem of cosmic impacts.
And that's incredibly irresponsible
because as I said a moment ago,
it is a solvable problem.
It is within the limits of our technology.
It would require a global cooperative
effort to sweep our cosmic environment
clean,
but it could be done and a side product
of that global corporation might be a
friendlier, more nurturing, more
loving, more positive human community.
It is very odd that we have
this infant towel nature,
even as grown adults and
world leaders that we don't,
we do like to nor eminent danger.
As long as it hasn't affected
us in the past, there's,
there's no real moment we can point
to other than tongue goose Gha in,
you know,
photographic history,
modern history where you
could take pictures of things.
When we had a gentleman,
if I can,
if I can pull up on that very point
that the evidence is compelling that the
Tunguska event was an object then fell
out of the Taurid meteor stream that
happened at the peak of the
beat of tourists in June,
1900 and eight that it is extremely
likely that that Tunguska object came from
the Taurid meteor stream because we
were passing through the Taurid meteor
stream at exactly that time and what
the tango Ska object is estimated to be
between 60 and 190 meters in diameter.
So it's not a very big object.
It's not a kilometer scale object.
It's a, it's, it's, it's big,
but it's not that big. It doesn't
even hit the earth. It's an Airburst.
It explodes in the sky above fortunately
and uninhabited area of Siberia.
But the devastation is huge.
It wasn't even noticed for some years
afterwards until scientific teams went in
and studied the area and discovered
that 80 million trees across 2000 square
kilometers had been completely
flattened by that airburst. Uh,
and to put that in context, 2000 square
kilometers is the size of London.
So anybody who knows London is aware
that there's a ring road around London
called the m 25 if that air best
had taken place over central London,
everything of London out as far as the
m 25 would have been gone completely.
Is that what it looks like
today? Great. Pretty close to,
there's like a hundred years later,
there's no trees and if you've got,
you're looking at above there,
you're looking at the black and whites
that were taken in the early 19 hundreds.
God, yeah. Which, which revealed the
extent of this, uh, of this damage.
So it's just stupid of us not to
pay a bit more attention to this,
especially when we have the
tech to actually do something
about it. We have that,
that nature though, when it comes to
climate designee, a curious denial,
there's a denial of the role of
cataclysms in the human story. And there,
there is even a word for that in, in
science and it's called uniformitarianism.
And,
and this is a particular philosophy of
science where the view is that everything
is, we see it in the world today
is how things have always been.
So if we don't see cataclysms today and
they're not playing a major part in our
story today,
then there weren't cataclysms and they
didn't play a major part in our story in
the past. That's why, although it's
before the time of human beings,
when the evidence that the dinosaurs
were made extinct by a comet or an
asteroid, a first came out, um,
Lewis and Walter Alvarez, the father,
son team who were behind that science
were ridiculed by their colleagues and
they were telling us absolutely absurd.
Of course,
no cosmic event could have
made the dinosaurs extinct.
They spent 10 years taking that ridicule
until they found the crater in the Gulf
of Mexico.
Since then,
the whole scientific community has
accepted that the course of life on this
planet was radically
changed by a cosmic impact.
And you know,
I like to joke about it,
but it was a cosmic impact that was big
enough literally to turn dinosaurs into
chickens because that's what's left
of the time. So align is, you know,
the birds.
And at the same time,
skulking in those prime evil forests is
this little mammal and it looks a bit
like a shrew,
a 65 million years ago going nowhere.
The dinosaurs ruled the earth,
then the cosmos intervenes.
The dinosaurs are swept out of the way.
And what happens,
the mammals start to evolve very rapidly
and they start to occupy niches that
were previously closed to them. And the
bottom line is we would not be here.
The human species would not be here.
We would not be having this conversation
if the dinosaurs had not been made
extinct 65 million years ago. Uh,
so these are world changing events.
And my argument is that such a world
changing event occurred between twelve
thousand eight hundred and eleven
thousand six hundred years ago,
and it's high time.
We paid more attention to it.
Is there any evidence that there was
other species of human beings that existed
in the Americas,
like we're finding in Russia and there's
many of them that are being discovered
all over the world now,
these subspecies of human beings.
Yeah. Um, this is, uh, an
issue that I go into in,
in America before.
And what first drew me into it
was Dennis over K in Siberia.
I think everybody's head of the
neanderthals and these days,
I think everybody's head
of the Denisovans as well.
A lot of people have a lot of, well,
I guess a lot of people haven't, but,
but first of all,
let's take the neanderthals.
For a long time it was held that
the neanderthals were stupid,
primitive subhumans
shambling lacking symbolism.
Turns out that that's not true at all.
The latest scientific evidence on the
neanderthals is that they were symbolic
creatures. That they did do art,
that they were in every sense human,
and they were in every sense human because
anatomically modern humans interbred
with neanderthals,
you can't interbreed with another species.
They clearly were a human human beings,
but they looked rather different from us.
And that's why certain populations in
the world today still have three to 5% of
Neanderthal DNA.
Then in Russia,
in Dennis serve a cave, they find a
single pinky bone from a little finger.
And, uh, they do the DNA testing on it.
They're able to get a
complete a genome from it.
And what they discover is
this isn't in the, and Athol,
this isn't an anatomically modern human
being. This is another human species, uh,
who they named the Denisovans.
They think they're more closely related
to neanderthals than they are to
anatomically modern humans, but they're
clearly and other human species.
And they also interbred with anatomically
modern humans and Denisovan DNA
survives,
interestingly enough,
it's a predominantly in Australasia,
uh,
in Papua New Guinea and
amongst Australian aborigines.
So as part of the research for this book,
I went to Dennis have a cave.
I had an amazing, actually just
incredible trip to Russia. I hadn't,
I hadn't expected it to be like
that at all. Siberia. I mean,
America is vast, but my
God, crossing Siberia,
this endless rolling plains,
you know, this just vast area.
How did you cross it?
We took a car, a w well,
you can't travel independently in Russia.
It's very difficult. You have to get,
you have to get permission and you have
to state in advance where you're going
to be stopping off that. So
what I found, and I just did,
so through the Internet was a, was a
local guy called Sergey Corgan, um,
who had a little tour business,
um, in, in, in, in Siberia,
in the city of novel Sybil risk.
I got in touch with him.
He found a translator who would
translate my emails and I said,
we want to make this journey to Dennis
over cave and can you set this up for us
and get all the permissions. And, and
he did. And so we flew into novice,
a bisque Sergei and his
translator who turned out to be a,
a Russian student who spoke good English,
joined us.
And we did this immense
journey across Siberia. Oh,
it took us three days to get to, to
get to Dennis over cave, three days,
three days of driving every day.
Some stopping off along the way.
Incredible hospitality of the,
of, of the Russians that we were,
we're amongst very independent people,
people who are living out there in
the wilderness and who actually do,
do know how to survive.
As the first time I've ever
drank milk fresh from the cow,
literally milked right out of the
cow and poured down my throat. I was,
it was delicious. And the cream,
I mean thick, thick cream.
So it was a lot of things about Russia
that surprised me. Dennis over caves.
A fascinating, beautiful
place to visit. It's another,
it's another example of a missing chapter
in the human story that is beginning
to be pieced together.
It's obvious now that we were not alone,
that there were multiple
other human species who were
human enough to interbreed
with us and leave leave DNA.
And there's Dennis [inaudible] species
was only discovered in like, was it 2000?
So I'm very recently the 2007. It's a
very, it's a very recent discovery and,
and it's a little behind art. Hmm. Did
they leave behind art better than that?
They left behind, um,
certain physical objects,
which are extremely hard to explain.
One of them is a green stone bracelet.
Uh,
and that bracelet is
in the form of a talk,
which was therefore slipped on sideways
onto the hand. It's not a full ring. Um,
and a hole has been drilled through the
bracelet and from that whole it's been
possible to reconstruct that a pendant
was hung then the archeologists,
there it is.
Then the archaeologists started to take
a look in detail at the drill marks on
that hole.
And what they discovered
was a huge anomaly that that
was drilled with a stable
fixed drill and it was drilled
at extremely high speed. It's a,
this is thought to be
40 or 50,000 years old.
There is not supposed to have been any
such technology in that period that was
capable of drilling with
a stable fixed to drill.
And yet there it is there it appears.
So there,
there are also incredible,
very fine needles,
bone needles that the
Denisovans made very long ones,
which suggests that they were
stitching very heavy stuff together.
And the suggestion has been were
they making skin boats, for example,
to to use to navigate that would explain
how they managed to get themselves to
Australia,
which is where the largest amount
of Denisovan DNA survives today.
There's one of those,
there's one of those needles so that
there are indications of strangely out of
place technology amongst
the dentist servants,
which is 20 30,000 years
earlier in the human story.
Then it then it should be those kinds
of needles, that kind of bracelet.
You could expect to find them in what
archeologists call the Neolithic,
but to find it in the Paleolithic is very
puzzling and very odd and it suggests
that the Denisovans were certainly not
a sat shambling sub subhumans that they,
they were refined creatures.
Can you find out what year the
discover the Denisovans? Jamie,
can you Google that real quick?
I want to say it's in the two
thousands but I mean a ma,
imagine that human beings have
been around for this long.
Here we are in 2019 and within the last
decade or so, they figured this out. Yeah.
We're discovering new
stuff about ourselves.
We're discovering that our story
is much richer, much more textured,
much more lead than we thought it was.
It's not a simple story.
It's a very complicated story.
And we ourselves are a hybrid species.
We are,
we are the result of interactions with
all kinds of different looking human
beings. And the end, the
end result is ourselves.
So it's not just that we carry
neanderthal or Denisovan DNA in a sense.
We are neanderthals and
Denisovans, uh, you know,
and have their, they are part of the
anatomically modern human human heritage.
So you make a good point.
The fact that this is only being
discovered now and that it's an incredibly
important, I mean, it, it completely
rewrite the story of our ancestry.
The notion,
the notion of 19 seven 1970s Oh,
the real work that's been done in Dennis
Server cave has been done in the two
thousands from,
from 2006,
2007 that's when the major papers have
been 2008 there had been published,
which have,
which have revealed the genome of the
dentist's servants and revealed the
dentist's over and connection to
two anatomically modern humans.
The fact that we're only
finding this out now that we,
that we told the story of our past and
weren't aware of this raises the question,
how much else in the story of our
past is there that we're not aware of?
Let's stop being so arrogant,
so sure of ourselves.
So confident in our findings
that's be more tentative.
Let's keep an open mind and
see and see where it takes us.
That's the main message that I have
from, from all of this. And I think,
um, and I hope that this will be
an effect of this book. I'm not,
I'm not kidding myself that the
archeologists are going to jump on board,
uh,
overnight particularly.
So since I'm very critical of American
archeology in this book and I'm critical
of it specifically and explicitly because
of the dominance of the Clovis first
model for so long,
which prevented the research taking place.
And I have to say archaeologists like
to insult me by calling me a pseudo
scientist.
I can't think of anything
more pseudoscientific than
the Clovis first doctrine,
which locked American archeology for
50 years in a particular framework,
which we now know was totally wrong.
Nothing good about it at all. Uh,
a complete mistake.
What I'm hoping the book will do a in
the long run is that it will lead to more
attention being focused on the Americas.
This is a very neglected
area of the world. Uh,
as far as deep and ancient
archeology goes. Um, it's,
the recent history of the Americas
has been relatively well studied,
but the deep and ancient history has
not been, has not been well studied.
And I think America is going to contain
revelations for us about our story and
about our past.
And I'm serious when I,
when I suggest that America is the most
plausible and the most likely home base
for a lost civilization. If you're going
to propose a lost civilization, you need,
there are certain preconditions. You need
a, you can't have it on a small island.
There's got to be a large land mass with
enormous resources and the ability for
population to grow and for those
resources to be, to be mobilized.
And what I suddenly realized,
you asked earlier why I,
why I started to write this book at all
is what the new evidence is pointing to
is that the Americans have
been wrongly neglected.
That here we have a giant continental
land mass with extraordinary resources
that has just been ruled out of
the story of human civilization.
But once we take account of the fact that
there was a giant cataclysm over North
America 12,000,
800 years ago,
and once we start looking
as I do in America before,
at the incredible deep indepth
similarities between, for example,
the religious system of ancient
Egypt and the religious system of the
Mississippi Valley, then you
realize that you're into, uh,
into a global mystery here.
And that the answer to that mystery may
not at all be in the old world and may
very much be, uh, in the, in
the Americas. See, it's odd.
I mentioned Manville earlier on.
It's kind of odd that we should find a,
what is essentially the
ancient Egyptian religion, uh,
manifesting in the
symbolism of Mountville,
the ascent to Orion that
transit to the Milky Way,
the journey along the Milky Way.
Very,
these are very specific
and idiosyncratic ideas.
And what makes it doubly od is Manville,
isn't that old Manville as a site
is about a thousand years old.
Ancient Egypt had already been gone
completely from the world for at least 600
years before Manville was created.
The end of ancient Egypt. There's,
there's Mountville and uh,
w w what we're looking at in the
foreground is mount B and we're looking at
Monday and the in the, in
the distance, um, and, and a
complete circle of mountains.
What w what is odd about it is we find
the system of ancient Egyptian ideas in
Moundsville 500 years after ancient Egypt
has gone from the world. The Romans,
the Romans were the end of ancient Egypt
by 400 Aad, ancient Egypt has gone.
Manville doesn't even exist then,
but 600 years later it is created and
it manifests the entire set of ancient
Egyptian ideas.
Clearly it did not get that as a result
of direct transmission from ancient
Egypt unless they were time travelers.
The only way I think it could have got
it is as a result of a legacy passed down
from a much earlier civilization that has
influenced and affected many different
parts of the world and the
characteristics of that civilization,
the shamanistic heart of it, the use
of altered states of consciousness.
The focus on those are amongst the reasons
that I would suggest that America is
the place that we should be looking and
the big mysteries are in the areas that
were so devastated at the end of the
last ice age up in the north of North
America, the channel scab
lands in particular, and
then the Mississippi Valley,
the whole story of the Mississippi Valley.
Yes, Manville is a thousand years old,
but then you can go back to
poverty point in Louisiana,
which is 2,700 years old.
You can go to Watson break in Louisiana,
which is 5,500 years old.
You can go to sites like Conley,
which are 8,000 years old.
The system keeps on going back
and disappearing back into time.
And I think the most fruitful new work
on exploring the origins of civilization
is going to occur counter
intuitively in the Americas.
The very last place on earth
that archeologists have
ever thought to look where
to what to mainstream, uh, archeologists,
what do they think caused those drill
marks? And then Dennis over and bracelets,
if not really explained
it. Um, the, the Russian,
the Russian archeologist who published
the report on that, uh, are them,
are themselves mystified by it and they
realize that it's dynamite. It's an,
it's an explosive discovery. Uh, it's
a, it's an out of place technology.
And so they're trying to explain
how come fixed stable drilling,
which we thought was
introduced first in the,
in the Neolithic maybe seven,
8,000 years ago.
How come that is now found in a
site that's 40 or 50,000 years old?
And so all those bracelets,
oh yeah, absolutely.
Those bracelets or 40,000 at the May, they
may have been older. There's, there's,
there's recent research
suggests suggesting that
they may go back 65 to 70,000
years,
the extremely ancient and therefore,
and therefore they're an out-of-place
technology which doesn't fit with the
timeline of history that we've been out
of place. It was very, very out of place.
Very, very, very odd
feature that we have here.
So what this says to me
is that we as a species,
and I've this,
I guess this is kind of my pet phrase,
we are a species with Amnesia
is my favorite phrase of
we have forgotten so much
more about ourselves than we remember.
And what the process of history and
archeology should really be about is a
process of remembering.
We shouldn't be imposing our ideas of
what we should have been on the past.
We should allow the past to
speak for itself when it does.
So it speaks eloquently.
Um,
one of the sites that we visited and
explored for America before was sip ant
mound in Ohio. I don't know if
you've ever been there. You know,
I've heard of it though. It is an amazing,
Jamie is from Ohio. Your Beta. Yeah.
Jamie and I were talking about it
earlier. There's seven man, there's a,
there's an aerial view of that is Correy.
Here's the thing. You see that beautiful.
You see the head end of separate man.
They're so Santa and I went there
at the summer solstice in uh,
2017.
We were there on June 21st,
2017 and my wife Santha is a photographer
and we acquired a drone for this
specific purpose and she flew the drone
up 400 feet above separate mount and we
sat it up there watching the sunset.
And what happens on the summer solstice,
and you can only see it
perfectly with adrenaline there.
There's pictures of it in
the, in the book here. Uh,
what happens on the summer solstice,
you can see it from ground level,
but you get up 400 feet,
you really get it.
The head of that serpent is pointing
directly at a niche in the distant hills
through which the sun sets on the summer
solstice on the longest day of the year.
So it's a, it's a sky ground
alignment perfection that is,
that is taking place there. It's a
beautiful, it's a beautiful thing to see,
to watch that sun majestically sinking
down into the horizon and see this
awesome figure of the
serpent gazing directly.
I've attic with its jaws open
almost as though it's about to,
about to swallow the sun.
And then we remember that there are other
sites around the world which are also
aligned to key moments of the, of the
solar year aligned to the winter solstice.
For example,
the Temple of Karnak in Upper Egypt.
That kilometer long access targets
exactly the rising point of the sun on the
winter solstice. One of the
interesting things about serpent mound,
and I urge anybody listening to this go
visit serpent mound and especially go
there on the summer solstice
cause that's the moment.
That's the marriage of heaven and earth.
That's when Skyann ground unite in,
in Majesty at, uh, at,
at, at that place. Um,
but one of the mysteries
of serpent mound concerns,
how old is this mound? Really?
How, how, how far back does it go?
And there have been arguments that uh,
that there's a group of archeologists
who would like it to be just a thousand
years old and they attributed
it to a culture of called
the fort ancient culture.
There's another group of archeologists
in my view who have done much more
thorough, thorough work who
attributed to the Edina culture.
The thing about which goes
back to 2,300 years ago or so,
there's evidence for an earlier
construction enterprise.
It looks like the site has
been continuously reconstructed
and remodeled as we
would do with any sacred site.
If it begins to wear down,
you remodel it and then you get later
organic material being introduced to the
site. That may give you the impression
that the site is only that old.
What's intriguing about serpent mound
is it stands on a natural ridge and that
natural ridge, and this is entirely
an accident of heaven and earth,
that Natural Ridge, the
head end of it, if you like,
is naturally oriented to
the summer solstice sunset.
Somebody a long time ago noticed that
natural orientation and they decided to
monumentalize it.
Here was a place where earth whispered
to sky the earth in her own nature,
looked directly at the place on the
horizon where the sun was setting.
This was a highly significant place.
This place mattered.
So they then created serpent mound
on top of it. They memorialized it.
They turned it into a,
into a special special place that human
beings had had a hand in making to honor
the marriage of heaven and earth.
And what I found researching this book
is that serpent mound is not alone in
that respect.
A lot of people are puzzled
by Stonehenge in England.
A stone Henge is built on Salisbury
plain and there are two kinds of big
megaliths that Stonehenge,
one of them are called sostenes and
the other called the bluestones.
The blue stones,
we know for sure were brought along way.
They were brought from Wales to
Stonehenge, a distance of about 150 miles.
The sarsens are found in abundance
on a place called the mob downs,
which is about 20 miles from Stonehenge.
But until very recently it was thought
there were no sauces on Salisbury plain
at all.
An archeologist couldn't understand why
Stonehenge wasn't built on the Marlboro
downs weather,
whether it's big Saas and stones,
the 20 to 30 10 megaliths where available
locally and didn't have to be brought
there.
Very recent research,
2018 research has provided the answer
that two of those sauces were naturally in
position all the time at at Stonehenge.
And they are sauce and
stone 16 and the heel stone.
And if you stand behind and stone 16
and look at the Hillstone at dawn on the
summer solstice you see the sun rising
in direct alignment with the view and the
heel stone is like the site on the
barrel of a rifle targeting the sun.
And that was there naturally
it was speaking to sky.
The ancient saw that they
decided this was sacred.
They went to huge lengths
to bring the sauces,
the rest of the Sarsens from the mob
redounds to create the big stone circle at
Stonehenge and meant to put
the blue stones inside it.
But initially what they were celebrating
was a natural union of Heaven and
earth. And that brings us
to the notion of as above.
So below that we are connected
to the cosmos. That it is,
that it is part of our heritage. We in
modern cities, forget the cosmos exists.
We have all kinds of tech that can look
at astronomy, astronomy programs, we can,
we'd all do that.
But actually looking at the stars is
something that's very difficult for people
who live in cities to do where
we're cut off from the cosmos,
we're cut off from the
notion that it is sacred,
that it matters to the human creature.
And what,
what the ancient seem to have had done
is to realize how vital that connection
is and to memorialize it and to celebrate
it and to draw our attention to the
intimate connection between ground Scott.
Yeah.
Light pollution sort of fuels our infant
tile existence and a lot of ways, right?
Because it doesn't constantly remind us
that we're a part of this great thing.
Yeah. Light, light, light, light pollution
is, uh, is, is, is a huge factor.
It's very easy to forget that we live
in a universe. Very easy to forget that.
Very easy to,
to believe that it's just about
these cities that we live in and the,
and the intimate concerns of our,
of our daily lives.
But when in fact we're part of
something much, much bigger. And my God,
I mean,
it's,
it's a mystery enough to be
born a human being at all.
Yes. You know, just to be
alive is a, is, is, is,
is an extraordinary mystery.
Yes.
To have the ability to love, uh, to, to,
to feel emotions, um, to
understand beauty, to be moved by,
by, by a symphony. All of all of
these things we take for granted,
but actually they're deeply mysterious.
We don't really know what we are or who
we are and which is one of the reasons
I'm so fascinated by, uh,
Rick Strassman's work. You,
you presented his film,
Dmt, the spirit molecule,
and on my upcoming speaking to her, I'm
going to be doing an event with Rick, uh,
on the 14th or 15th of May in Sedona.
I think it will be the first time that
Rick has spoken publicly for quite a
while. Rick has a colleague
called Andrew Gallimore, uh,
who teaches at the
University of La Kinawa, uh,
in Japan and Rick and Andrew have
together developed a technology,
uh,
for releasing DMT into human volunteers
in a very slow drip that will keep them
in the DMT state if they
wish for hours on end.
And the intention,
the intention is to use this technology
to explore and map the DMT realm.
When do I sign up? Soon as possible.
Where do I, it's it's very close.
Imperial College.
It looks like Imperial College London
is going to deploy this technology in
further research into DMT and that that
research is not going to be purely and
simply into the therapeutic
potential of a psychedelic,
which is very important research to do.
It's going to be an investigation into
the nature of reality using a psychedelic,
the mysterious nature of reality.
And it is art.
And you know this from personal experience
that when you get plunged into that
DMT realm,
it is so different from the realm
of our daily daily world filled,
filled with geometry,
filled with these sprightly intelligences
completely internally coherent.
How can that be generated by the brain
or are are we dealing with some other
level of reality that we
haven't encountered yet?
I think that ancient cultures
and in particular my lost
civilization were deeply
involved in exploring the
mysterious nature of reality, um,
and used the plant medicines
as part of that process.
When it comes to the serpent mound where
the head points in the summer solstice
is that take into account the procession
of the equinoxes in terms of the
position of the summer solstice sun
on the horizon is not effected by the
procession,
however it is affected by another,
another factor which is a slight
nod on the axis of the earth,
a nod but not a wobble, not a
wobble and a nod and, and a,
it's called a mutation and the,
the access of the earth
nods back and forward over a
cycle of about 41,000 years.
And that can,
that does adjust the position of sunrise
on the horizon over a very long period
of time. And it would, in theory, if
this idea can be taken seriously enough,
it would in theory be possible to use
very precise observations using the latest
modern tech,
not simply being up there in a drone and
seeing the general connection between
the position of the sun on the
horizon and the head of serpent.
Marty would be possible to refine that
and actually say astronomically the
precise date on which serpent mound must
have been first created to precisely
target the rising sun on the
equinox. Wow. On that note,
which did three hours did we buy?
I would,
I would ask your listeners and viewers
while we're talking about Ohio,
don't forget about Newark and high bank.
These are two incredible,
amazing, absolutely stunning,
gorgeous geometrical sites.
It's sad,
but one of them is preserved within a
private golf course. Oh, no. However,
it's not so sad because if it hadn't been
preserved within a private golf course,
it would be gone completely.
More than 90% of the native
American earthworks that
were documented in the 19th
century are gone now.
They'd been plowed under for agriculture.
That's another part of our missing
story there. We're looking at Newark,
see that octagon and circle combination
that's repeated at another site called
high bank,
which is 60 miles away.
And the octagon circling gimme
a gimme a large image that,
so an overlay or is that
what it actually looks for?
It actually looks like
that's, I mean that's, that's,
that's a graphic based on it.
Well the octagon circle combination
in the top left of the image are best
preserved.
The other bits are not so well preserved.
And the reason the octagon circle our
best preserved is cause they're in a
private golf club where otherwise
they would have been plowed under.
The interesting thing is that that octagon
circle combination is 60 miles from
high bank,
but there's another octagon circle
combination there and it is oriented that
precisely 90 degrees to that one.
That speaks of high science in the
Mississippi Valley are very, very,
very long time ago.
There's so much to explore and so much
to investigate and so much to inquire
into an America.
Uh,
it's just an incredible land and its
mysteries have been hidden from us.
And I'm hoping with this book that I have
managed to pull the veil back a little
bit on those mysteries, and if we really
coming to the end of earth, he said,
really three hours. Oh my God. If we,
if we're really coming to the end
of our three hours, can I repeat?
I would love to see readers
of my books at my events.
I'm doing three events in
Canada, Vancouver, Montreal,
and Toronto, and I'm doing something like
17 or 18 events in the United States.
I'm just speaking continuously,
uh,
right the way across the u s I wish I
could visit every state in the u s but my
goodness,
this is an enormous country.
Every state in the U s is as big as
the entire British isles, you know? Uh,
but I'm in visiting as many as I am.
I'm going to be giving
illustrated presentations.
I'll be signing books afterwards.
I'll be taking pictures.
I would like to meet my readers
and please check out my website,
Graham hancock.com look at
the talks and events page,
and you'll see where all these events
are occurring over the next seven weeks.
We're on the 22nd of April today.
I will not leave North American
until the 5th of June. Oh, wow.
I hope I see you again then
in, listen, thank you so much.
You're a treasure and this book is,
I can't wait to get into it America
before and the audio book is available now
as well. Yeah, the audio books available.
I read it. Thank you so much, Graham.
It's always a pleasure having you here.
I'm really, really appreciate you.
Thanks for having me back on, Joe Graham
Hancock, ladies and gentlemen. Bye.
Okay.